all right and we are live
and travis is laughing welcome to the
last word
front cat fresh for that friday night
can't fire low incognito and ibantas
eman what's going on it's just a regular
day right nothing special going on
yeah it's just pretty chill no news
yesterday no company you know change of
so much happened yesterday we have a lot
to talk about it's kind of insane but we
have an amazing guest joining us
royalty of the gaming world so we've got
to introduce him properly so
tossing it right back today it's yours
sir let's go man
welcome to the last word episode number
124.
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a true lord who is
not only legally befitting of the title
but is also an absolute connoisseur when
it comes to the world of destiny
whether it be his passion for the
grimoire or insightful hot takes
all done with mcclunky flair
introducing the reviewer slash online
personality for ign
and a panelist of destiny's fire team
chat
the lord of suits and neckties
unapologetic titan whose photo image has
finally blessed the ftc banner
live from san francisco and kind enough
to make his debut
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord ty guy travis how we doing
sir
mcclunkey my friends may i say that
is the greatest intro i have ever
probably will ever receive so thank you
very much for that
come on you gotta shoot for the stars
right that's just where you begin
i feel like a star you've really
welcomed me here at this campfire so
thank you
absolutely absolute pleasure to have you
at the last word man
big fan love the energy you bring to ign
and fire team chat
obviously we had a chance to podcast
together on fire teen chat which was
awesome and uh i had to throw the fight
it was that running joke recently and
you finally were there it's like he has
made it
he has he's ascending but shout out to
our boy cj gibson because cj put out a
funny tweet
he's like well at least because they
have a graphic when cj was on
and the five team chat logo covers his
face diagonally
so he's like at least that didn't happen
to you yeah
shout out to travis you're the grace is
actually visible yeah the graphics were
adjusted and all of a sudden oh we've
got space for the new guys cj's over
there like
discovered there's actually a story
behind that which is that it absolutely
was intentional
destin had been joking about they were
going to change the banner for years
cj was on 100 episodes and he was like
how am i not on the banner yet like it
doesn't make any sense it you know i've
been on the show like people seem to
like me and my opinions like
put me on the banner yeah he's like put
me on the banner and so destin was like
all right cj
we're gonna take your head shots we're
gonna put you on the banner and so cj
goes through
the whole process of getting his head
shots taken he dresses up gets his hair
cut
and then the week that he gets put on
the bander they put the logo right over
his face
that's it for being messy and petty oh
it was great dude and then for the for
the last week
any time i saw him i would just crack up
around the office
just absolutely laugh at them
absolutely classic man otherwise what's
been going on man
you know just uh trying to grind out the
festival the lost i'm late to the game i
i just got done reviewing gentian impact
for ign
yeah i put over 150 hours into that game
in two weeks so
i absolutely just like you know was was
uh
was sucked into that and time to get the
review out so
yeah um now i'm back in destiny uh and
getting ready for my next ign review
which is
uh destiny 2 beyond light or the xbox
series x and pc is what i'm going to be
thinking about we got that early preview
so what information can you tell us or
what's this
what's it looking like yeah break nda
right now come on yeah i'm going to go
ahead and tell you everything i know
which is that uh you get it the same day
we do
pre-order destiny to be on life
getting disclaimer well trained get your
statues
get your statues and your pre-order
weapons and catalyst please
there you go and yeah so so uh that's
going to be really exciting as you guys
know and uh
see you online if you're on pc or xbox
so very much
i've dragged this man to pc so yeah
we're there i'm
i'm focused
yeah i was like i know i was like it's
where to play and even now he's like
i gotta i gotta be on pc for even a
little bit longer i was like yeah
because it's such a hard place to be
they won't let me just because crucible
is unplayable
i'm sorry lucy's garbage i'm sorry this
is not good you
you know what you for that statement
every week you're allowed to come back
cameo that was classic right there thank
you for the pvp guys
oh it's brutal like here i i respect pc
as a platform for people who really have
the energy for it
it it sure pays dividends and that sort
of thing but
it's just toxic man as a crucible main
pc is just unpalatable you can't really
play it on it so yeah
it's just a little spooky especially
with i was playing with playing gambit
and people
cheating i'm like that's gambit i saw
that
i was like first of all who plays gambit
first of all
we got a lot of history with uh travis
here so let's start with the questions
about what you got from them
i might steal one from you but i want
this story you may already have it i
don't know
i've got to know mcclunkey
oh i know monkey i think i know that
yeah
okay so so there's a there's a there's
kind of like a
spectrum of knowledge when it comes to
mcclunkey and
it is based on how well you are familiar
with star wars
so yeah do you know where mcclunky's
from
in general i don't know
the phrase and our viewers may not
either so feel free to
please because i had to research as you
know uh george lucas has sort of been
obsessed with changing the original
trilogy of star wars movies
since he released them and there's some
pettiness involved originally he changed
it because his
ex-wife uh did the editing on the
original star wars movie and so he
re-edited it so that he could avoid
giving her royalties when they got a
goddess
so that's why yeah it's pretty cold but
anyway
so that's that's like a little bit of
star wars trivia for you i'm a huge star
wars
yeah so that that's that's sort of how
it started and and then you know
he he invented the lucasfilm sort of
pioneered
3d animation you know they created the
technology that would eventually become
pixar
they were the first ones to have like
you know the the 3d rendered
you know stuff in the prequel trilogy
and and he put them
originally into the original trilogy uh
after you know the vhs special edition
remake which a lot of people hated
um and so ever since then he's just sort
of unapologetically
changed the star wars original trilogy
and we thought it was over
because five years ago he sold the
rights to star wars
to disney and we were like all right
well he's not allowed to just like
i change things whenever i want to you
know like
he like one of the things he just
decided was there'd been a question for
years of like
what is obi-wan kenobi's home planet and
somebody asked him it was jon stewart
was interviewing him at star wars
celebration john stewart is a huge star
wars fan
and he said hey uh you know what's
obi-wan's home planet and george lucas
just because he was annoyed at
continuing to hear the question he said
he's from the stu john system
and then that became canon no just like
that
like oh he's from the stu john system
your name is jon stewart i'm tired of
hearing it
and it's canon just like that so he he
like had this magical power to just
change star wars whenever he wanted and
and fans were not having it they're like
not a fan of
his ability to do this and then finally
disney re-released the original trilogy
on disney plus it was the first time we
had seen disney create
uh you know the kind of flex their
muscles with the with the original
trilogy
and when they did it there was one
change again
to the original star wars trilogy and uh
that change was done uh
not by disney it was apparently changed
by george lucas
before right before he sold the rights
to disney
and that changed for whatever reason was
to the han solo greedo duels
in the cantino in a new hope all right
and so
this is like one of the most hated
scenes in star wars
because george lucas changed it
originally
han solo shoots greedo without a word
and it sort of sets up this arc of
redemption for han that he's sort of
like this ruthless killer and then he
kind of gains a heart of gold throughout
the trilogy it's a really nice arc
george lucas ruins it by trying to make
the movie more of a kid film
i'm sorry i could talk about star wars
for hours knowledge
but uh yeah so george lucas in a in
in an effort to make it more
kid-friendly change the scene so that
greedo shoots first and han
using cgi dodges him by his character
just literally being moved
yeah like six inches to the left and
then fires back on greedo and so instead
it's like oh han was shooting in
self-defense he didn't just kill greedo
out of nowhere
right and so this new change in disney
plus was even worse
which is that not only does greedo shoot
first
but they do a close-up on greedo's face
and he says mcclanky
just like that and then it cuts back and
it shows
han solo dodging the move and shooting
back and mcclunkey
is hatiss if you speak a little hatis as
i do then you would know that mcclunkey
uh is is hatties for uh this is the end
for you and so it's
not only is greedo shooting first but
he's also
threatening oh he's talking he's saying
i'm gonna kill you
so that even more justifies han killing
him and therefore
even more ruins uh han solo's arc um
so yeah wow that is that is a little bit
of it so
yeah this this happened on a friday when
uh disney plus came to star wars and i
was watching it because i watched star
wars about
you know a couple times and it was on oh
it's on disney plus time to watch it
and i saw the mcclunky scene i was one
of the first people probably to see the
monk clunky scene it was like
20 minutes after it came out on disney
plus and it was just
it blew up the internet and we were
recording a fire team chat episode that
day
and i was we were talking about a fire
team shot how everybody had a
catchphrase except me
i didn't have a catchphrase i'm saying
so mcclunkey just showed up and i just i
threw mcclunky out there
and destin and brian weren't expecting
it and they started cracking up on the
show
and i was like that's it now that's my
kid's name
so now you have to say it like it
mcclunky or however it's cranky
yeah yeah you need a better impression i
don't know
you're good but yeah it's just so
awkwardly
unnecessary like it's hilarious it's
like
when i saw it i saw it i did my research
on it because i didn't know what it was
either to you
eloquently described it yeah i said
tweet i saw the tweet and i was like is
that
what because i know the star wars like
you had that then i saw the tweet and
i'm like
but i don't i didn't remember this i
haven't watched it recently so it was
like apparently
okay so we're getting there yeah it's a
it's a horrible star wars thing and the
way i like to think of it my use of
mcclunky because if you google mcclunkey
the first thing you get are a bunch of
articles about how that was weirdly
added to star wars and then you get me
it's like associated with like me as my
online identity
rock which i absolutely love
but but what i like to think of it is is
it's in this long tradition
of star wars fans taking terrible things
that happened to star wars
like the prequels and turning them into
beloved parts of it right like
now the prequels have been memed so hard
people love
the prequels and so i like to think of
my use of mcclunkey and using it as like
a replacement for
you know excelsior or or whatever
that's my contribution to turning a
terrible star wars thing into something
maybe people
i don't i don't know if you can start a
show better than that damn no we got it
we got all the history
we got to wrap it up right here we can't
do any better without just kidding
that's awesome man so yeah but like
tremendous history before before i know
we get into ign stuff
you know just gaming in general man you
know tremendous tremendous history
give us some of those like passionate
consoles and games that really kind of
sure got you excited and gaming before
your trajectory obviously
destiny what we know you for yeah yeah
so i i think
for me i've got introduced into video
games really early because my
my grandpa was like just a kind of a
an old-school nerd you know you know
back back when we were kids cognito
nerds had shame
you know yes yes yes
i kind of grew up in that uh now nerds
rule the world and they're allowed to
just be openly nerdy but uh
exactly yeah i'm a nerd who still has
shame
uh and uh i think that
my grandpa was in that and he uh the
atari was a really interesting system
because it came it had a few games but
the main feature of it was you could
write your own games and my grandpa
tried to do that and so he had this
really old atari and i had a few games
on it and i played it and i was sort of
obsessed with video games even from back
then
it was just like it was so cool and
nintendo came out with their stuff and i
played mario and it was like
i don't care what i'm doing in life i
want to be involved in video games
somehow like
i need to get uh need to need to have be
a part of this and so that
that sort of started me off but i think
you know the first
uh the first games that that like i
really remembered were legend of zelda
i know it was huge on me that was like a
game that just like blew me out of the
water
i did play i i was like a nintendo
fanboy but i played a lot of sega too i
played a lot of sonic uh the hedgehog
i played sonic the hedgehog as if me
saying sonic is going to confuse you who
i'm talking about in games
which sonic are you talking about a
cheeseburger
so yeah uh yeah you know i played a lot
of that um but for me
i think the moment that for me was like
a big defining moment was
when the xbox came out halo combat
evolved
that was a game that really changed my
life there was something about landing
on that ring
and then the world just sort of opening
up when on that first level
you know that just was like wait i can
do
and you go back now it's such a small
area there's like three inductives
you're doing
sandbox at the time felt liberated right
it was just like
you felt like how we feel about open
worlds now i guess back
then we've never seen anything like that
so we're like i can go there off in the
distance i can
i can do that like yeah good good point
valid yeah and it was it was a
shooter that was another thing is that
you weren't used to shooters were very
they were almost on the rails you were
in doom you were walking through
hallways you know that was the shooter
we're used to so
halo comet evolved changed everything
for me i the story was so
gripping and the fact about me that i'm
sure will come up in the show is that
i've read every halo
uh expanded new yorkers i've spent i
spent
hundreds of hours reading halo books i'm
like a huge halo nerd uh when it comes
to that stuff i'm just a nerd in general
but there are a few things that i go a
little extra with my dude
that is certainly one area um and and
then the multiplayer right like
playing with my friends at the time uh
not online but then
halo 2 came out and i played halo 2 for
years land party with 16 people in
someone's basement
that's amazing
that's right yeah and so i think ever
since xbox came out i've sort of really
identified with that community a lot of
my friends play on it i think that
they make a lot of really good games
obviously you know i review games for
ign i play
every console i play pc i'll you know
but xbox
those are where my boys at are at you
know like that's where my destiny family
is my bungee family from the halo days
um i betrayed mine to pc but see
yeah hey 60 frames a minute could you
continue
yeah that's uh so yeah that some of my
favorite games
um bioshock that game i think just like
raised the level of storytelling
obviously i like
mass effect and some of the the basic
games but
is honestly specific i gotta ask you
which which which one's your favorite
two one man
i've never actually touched a mass
effect
definitive remaster whatever that's
that's got my name all over it so yeah
yeah that that for sure is going to
happen it's like the worst kept secret
in yeah uh gaming it's like it's like
fable remember when xbox was pretending
for two weeks
for two years the fable wasn't a game
yeah and we all knew it was
uh yeah so i i think um
yeah i think that that is for sure
definitely something to hop on mass
effect that mass effect 2 was
peak mass effect in my book absolutely
suicide mission salute
yeah suicide mission exactly also
suicide mission one of the best
songs in gaming the soundtrack for that
song it's just like
got a ball get your blood pumping yeah i
forgot all about that good point
yeah you got to go back and listen to
that song it really like does a good job
of provoking all those memories uh
but yeah i'm one of those gamers who
legitimately not just saying this
legitimately likes every genre of video
game like there's no genre i stay away
from i love platformers
i love fighting games i love open world
rpgs
addicted to shooters i i have a pretty
good
breadth of of games and i feel like
that's um
in this world where there are a million
games and all of them want you to play
them
for a hundred hours a week like yes
that's the world we live in now
and i feel like that's narrowing you
know there's like the fortnight group
and there's the group that plays like
indies and there's the nintendo guys and
it's it's sort of rare to find somebody
like me who really has like a
a need i have to own every game i have
to play them all
yeah i have to know a little bit about
everything
it's tough it's tough
that's one of those when it comes to
time because i mean there's so many
games that'll come out
that either i've missed or i jumped on
and then another one pulled me away and
destiny pulls me back and because
there's stuff like horizon xerodon
started that one
legend of zelda breath of the wild came
right after that and then destiny
launched something i'm pretty sure in
april right after that so those two are
finished
sitting uncomplete amongst many other
things so when you're sitting there
saying like you want to play everything
like
there's so many that like i'm i'm with
you that i would love mine's pretty bret
like pretty wide breath too so it's like
it's nice to see
hey i just love like my sports games or
i love my shooters or
you know it's nice to have a good
variety unfortunately then you have so
much more that you have to try and get
your hands around and you usually don't
have
time it's tough man i think the the
proliferation of every game demanding so
much of your time
is like a kind of a problem probably in
video games
like it's sort of like the it's sort of
like the new issue is like
how do you keep up with destiny i
remember when
um the division came out
everyone was like how am i going to play
destiny and the division
and now that problem is like a million
times like
just playing destiny in the division
sounds like paradise to me like that
sounds like such an easy task because
now i have to keep up with a million
games that there's i have no chance of
keeping up with and
it's really tough man picking your
battles like i've had to skip
i remember i used to really like to play
like fifa when it would come out and now
it's like i haven't played fifa in years
it's just i don't have time for it
there's so many games that i
have to play absolutely so my secret has
been
the ones that really matter i try to
review them for someone
like i want if i can review them like i
reviewed horizon zero dawn specifically
because
i knew if i didn't review it i wouldn't
have time to ever play it so i found
a way to review it i got through the
game because you have to finish the game
if you're reviewing it
and then the ones that are less
important yeah
some outlets have different policies on
that certainly
ign makes you finish the game that's one
of the rules that's why i had to spend
150 hours
wow yeah you kind of agree to it so like
you have to pick your battles like they
were like travis do you want to review
gentian and i did a bunch of research
and i was like
i know just seeing that the next two
weeks of my life passing by
uh and and you know taking those battles
but if i didn't review it i never would
have played gunshot impact
i just don't have time for it i just
don't so i'm glad i took the review i
was like so when you take a project like
that and you're like say this is gonna
be a big thing or something along the
lines of if somebody's going to take
witcher
that's pretty giant undertaking as well
i mean do you just like talk to your
boss i'm going to review the witcher and
you hide in an office for like
two weeks just like sitting there
playing making your notes do it and is
it just like
that is your life for two weeks and you
don't really worry about anything else
or
is your job still pulling you multiple
other directions i didn't know how
dedicated
you get when that something like that's
on the line versus your day-to-day type
stuff
yeah no that's cute that you think that
we even get to go into the
when we get a game to review we go buy
for three weeks
i'm gonna be at home playing this every
minute of every day
because typically we don't have a lot of
lead time we've got like one week two
weeks and we have to hit embargo because
yeah all of your content is meaningless
if you don't get it at all
right yeah gentian impact was different
because it's a live game that we weren't
allowed to
review it in advance we had to play it
after the game came out and it also
wasn't really on anyone's radar like i
had never heard of the game and then all
of a sudden it sort of blew up
um and i think the reason it wasn't on
anybody's radar is because people were
already playing it it was like one of
those early access yeah
where people were playing it for like
six months before or whatever
um but yeah that typically if you're
reviewing a game like the witcher and
the person that's reviewing cyberpunk
obviously is like in a bunker in their
house basically
so they're they're you know they're
probably not coming in
unless you know they and they'll take
equipment home with them like we have a
bunch of community like
gaming rigs that you can pick up with a
handle and just like take
you know they're like portable so people
will take those for um
for for to home for work or whatever
other materials they need like a
monitor recording equipment all that
stuff and then and then come back when
they're ready
um and i will say just like the work the
worst experience i've ever had
is reviewing a vr game i don't know if
you guys are into vr
i've got i've not been i i've
traditionally not been in the vr
half-life alex changed my
completely that's my game of the year
right i just want to say a psa right now
since i have this platform to do this
half life alex yeah find a way to do it
i understand it's like
basically impossible to play like one
percent of the gaming community has
played it or whatever i should probably
play it
it is legitimately you know that how we
all thought vr was going to change
gaming and that was all we were going to
want like everybody was just going to be
in like those pods
yeah we all thought that was going to
happen
that the opposite happened it was like
demos and kind of like
uh they were just like showcasing like
hey isn't this a fun little
whack-a-mole game that you can probably
like beat saber i play beat saber for
hours but like
you're talking about one of those it's
not the most impressive game it doesn't
make you feel like you've been
transported to another world
half-life alex legitimately meets
that bar like it it makes every other vr
game
look like a tech demo it is
so immersive and so good and has so much
detail
like yeah you you have to play that game
anyway no no let me let me know because
you actually
making a good point shout out to e
because he's definitely him and wife
you're definitely the beat shape of
champions but
back to you she kicks my butt she's a
beast
she will she could go that and tetris
and i lose both
the woman is godly i don't know how
she's capable of these feats but
salute to someone but well i'm gonna say
it's funny you said that
because um on iron lord podcast we've
had uh bill still alone and he was one
responsible
for xbox backup pad then he went to
project xcloud
now he's doing off uh facebook vr and
he's been on me about because i'm
captain skeptical i'm like yeah this
ain't gonna work
and who's gonna buy this peripheral and
then
and he said the same thing you said
about half-life out he said until you
experience it
he's it's so transformative so now
hearing what you're saying
i have to explain like i need to know
what this
is about so yeah it just it figured out
all the stuff that annoyed me
about vr like for me i was gonna my plan
was to stay away from vr
until they got rid of the courts me too
because that's my concern you get to be
tethered yeah and so i was waiting for
that to happen obviously
oculus rift is there and that's the
wireless one but it's not really
it doesn't it's not a premium gaming
platform it's sort of like a downgraded
version that you can wear on your head
right
um this game it figured everything out
like you have gravity gloves so rather
than walking over to an item
you point at it and you pull it toward
you and then you catch it right
so you can shoot a guy with your gun and
then as he's falling you can pull his
gun
yank it toward you grab it and start
using it on some other people
that's awesome when you store items you
just pick them up and you
let go behind you like okay so if you're
if you run out of ammo you eject your
gun clip
you reach behind you grab pull it out
and you're holding the ammo put it in
like they just figured out all the stuff
that you really want
and it's so immersive like i got on all
fours to look under the bed to get some
ammo because you're kind of like looking
for supplies in the game
right and when i was done looking under
the bed i tried to put my hand on the
bed to help me get back
up that it's like that level where
you're like wait that bed's not there
like
this is crazy guys like oh okay so
yeah whenever i get a new graphics card
because i've got a 1080 ti and it does
pretty good in beat saver and stuff but
if i want to go like
deep on alex i think like get to the
next level yeah give me 30 80 something
like that
just push it to the max so it can be
full detail that would be
that sounds amazing man that yeah that's
one so i was gonna actually ask you
half-life 2 is put on this like crazy
pedestal
would you knock it off and put alex up
there instead now
so i would have not put half-life 2 on
that pedestal knife
to be honest like here's the thing i
respect the hell
out of half-life 2. when it came out it
did some stuff with like physics
and in the in-game engine that has never
been done before
but it's not been my cup of tea i've
never been really drawn to the story
that much
i think that the main character is kind
of bland i've had issues with it
that i think you know it just didn't
connect with me as much
half-life alex made me want to go back
and play half-life one and two like it
wow
it just it really was that at that level
that it was so good so yeah
i'm a believer in in vr now uh and and
could not recommend everyone enough buy
the index it's the best vr headset out
there it's way
too expensive it's a thousand bucks but
it's not it's it
once you get it here's the thing oculus
has all the exclusives because they got
that facebook money
right but you can get a mod to play all
of the oculus games on index and they
work well
so all i'm saying is i don't own an
oculus and i've been playing lots of
oculus games they're not great
the i think the biggest problem with
half-life alex is once you've played it
again going back to other vrt going back
yes you guys are not good yeah you could
probably beat saber for the experience
and then after that you're like
nah super hot is good on vr
if you yeah if you play super hot that
game on console as soon as it was
announced for vr i was like oh yeah that
would be better on vr wouldn't it and it
was
it's like and it's a different game too
so it's not like you're replaying the
old vr game it's got a separate
storyline and everything nice
just cool so absolutely yeah anyway my
point in all this is that reviewing vr
games is terrible that's how we got
started
way to bring it up full circle there you
go
yeah if you've never had to put a helmet
on and
be in a virtual reality world for a
couple hours a day i do not recommend it
it will make especially if it's i
reviewed no man's sky and i had to play
a lot of vr for that and that's one of
those games where the frame rate
is not it's psvr the frame rate is not
fast enough
for your eyes and i was just throwing up
like two times a day and it's like those
you know you know when you throw up and
it's like because you have a brain
headache
it was one of those where like you're
feeling so feverish you can't like
control your body oh brutal man the
things we do
to review a game yeah this man out here
putting in work and putting his body
through literally blood sweat and tears
damn
yeah yeah not blood yet but i'm sure
we'll get there i was like i wouldn't be
super
like my fingers i just can't feel them
too much typing the war reviews too long
no i mean tremendous man i mean like i
said just to see everything that you
guys doing over there and then obviously
you know the the fire team chat changes
what a lot of people
know you're for man like how did that
whole thing get together with
destin and now uh what you got uh brian
right
brian brian malkowitz yeah and paul
tassie is sort of like the unofficial
show's like the full chance yeah he's
like on he's everywhere that man
we just had him he's great yeah he was
on he's on actually this
our episode of fire team chat is going
to start airing during this podcast or
during this recording so
uh he's on this week's episode
absolutely i tweeted out and he was like
all my worlds are colliding because like
dcp
than this than that yeah he's he's
something
yeah i need to get on dcp at some point
yeah but yeah
so so yeah fire team chat has been
around for a really long time and it
sort of has had a revolving
cast based on two things people playing
destiny
because you have to remember when fire
team chat started it was sort of
the first time that one video game had
its own especially
ign at ign we had a podcast for nintendo
xbox playstation
and then one that was like a grab bag
right like that had been our
our formula for a while and so it was
really weird to have
a podcast where it was like about one
game but we were seeing
our traffic for destiny was super high
and you know the joke
in the gaming community is people still
play destiny at the time like
and now obviously they still do that's
like no question there
but at the time it was like yeah they're
still playing destiny lots of people and
we're getting a million plus views on
every article we publish about destiny
like this is a huge game
that's right um so he started that show
and at the time
so my backstory of how i got into
reviewing video games was
you know i had sort of done it as a
hobby after college i i
wrote freelance for different websites
anybody who would pay me to
to review and even then sometimes for
companies that wouldn't pay me to review
just
you know pro bono uh work and uh but
what my day job was i work in
advertising and i actually
started working for uh ign's parent
company which is a company called zif
davis they're like an old school
uh tech media conglomerate they own like
pc mag
and every other online publisher you've
ever heard of
um and so i i just by chance i got hired
on the same day
that zif davis bought ign and they told
us that we were moving into the ign
office
that was my first day at work wow like
uh and so
i i was a huge gamer i had been writing
reviews not for ign
obviously i was writing for indie
outlets but i had been writing reviews
for years
and i was just like wow i'm going to be
hanging out with ign crew that's
insane so you know we moved in and i was
i was working on the other side of the
office as the ign crew
and i would just start chit chatting
with people in the office about games
and
uh through that became really good
friends with a few people on the team
james duggan was one of my you know buds
i would have talked to all the time
yeah thug and duggan uh just talk about
how big his arms are
all day shout out to the gun
uh you know finnegan and i bonded over
our mutual
god all right yeah he's he really is in
the halo
yeah finnegan's really cool yeah he
works for uh
is it thunder thieves or something i
can't remember now okay gotcha
yeah um and cj and i uh cj is another
guy who he worked on the igen team but
he wasn't really on the
the coverage team he was a video guy um
similar to brian they they both worked
in in video and
and we all had this thing in common
which was that we
played destiny and so uh i would start
talking to destin
and anybody else who's playing destiny
around the office and they were like
this guy knows a lot about
destiny and and i was sort of like the
joke was i was like the unofficial
member of
cartoon chat because because i didn't
work for ign
but i was always in the conversation we
would be talking about destiny and then
they'd be like all right bye we're going
to go record the show now
and then i would go back to my office
and start working on those excel
spreadsheets you know like that was my
my my life okay kind of breaks my heart
hearing them
yeah yeah it was actually like that for
a while for
for a few people it wasn't just me like
it was like i think for the longest time
it was fran and i can't remember who was
originally on the show but it wasn't cj
yeah so i think it was actually that's
it
yes thank you and so and he's about to
go work for
nintendo oh yeah
actually there's an ongoing joke in ign
that uh like whoever becomes
the uh host of the nintendo podcast
works for nintendo like a year later
because that has just been happening
three times shout out to my wife
i like this cj was kind of also in my
camp he was like the unofficial extra
member of fire team chat where
he was always on the conversation but
never on the show because he wasn't
known for
being on on the show and so um in my in
my writing and my spare time for these
indie outlets
i started to cover destiny because i was
the biggest bungie fan in any of these
outlets like
that was just my specialty and so i
started covering destiny a lot doing
reviews for different sites on destiny
content writing articles
doing editorial pieces and then when the
taken king came out
i got invited to go to uh bungie's
headquarters for the first time
wow just as me and they were like you
can cover it and you can write for
whatever outlet you want we just want
you to be there and that's
i showed up and i i can't remember who
was there i think it was destin and he
was like
travis you're here what are you doing
what are you doing here
yeah and so uh and it happened years
later too when i went to go
uh cover it for pc and it was like a
year or two later it was like after
destiny 2 came out when they did the pc
and james duggan saw me and he was like
wait what don't you work
in the ign office for like the suits
like you're part of the corporate
group i was like yeah and i also covered
destiny
yeah so i was sort of crashing the party
working with ign and i remember
at the taken king event they did a
crucible thing i think the new mode was
the um what's the one where you have to
go and pick up the or
could kill confirmed that mode that the
supremacy
supremacy supremacy thank you i always
forget the name uh
yeah supremacy was coming out so they
had a whole crucible segment
i was so good at destiny crucible all
the time i will not claim to be the
world's greatest crucible player now i'm
a crucial mane i enjoy it but i
used to just be god tier i was so good
at destiny
so humble
not even humble i was very good tell him
what you did tell him what you did
so i ruined destin's
footage he was recording for ign and it
was just a montage of him getting
destroyed by me
every time
this is the best part of the story this
is the best story i went there just as
me
to record footage right right and i i
ruined destin's
crucible footage so bad it was
unsalvageable that he ended up using
mine for the ign footage
that they did under coverage so he was
just like hey so like can i borrow a few
clips cause like i'm not gonna put a
video of me just getting spawn killed
non-stop with a sniper rifle you know
and
yeah i think i was using uh i was using
icebreaker
it's just respawning and this is the
first time this is like public out there
you out in them right now
yeah i i think this is the first time no
actually
so yeah yeah yeah actually no no
that's not true we did it we remember
when they were doing the charity run a
couple months ago yeah
um i think it was right when covet
started we did a charity run and we were
talking stories and i think i told the
story and destiny
quickly like scooted by it and was like
anyway next time
i was gonna be like so travis why aren't
you on fire
chat next week what happened oh my god
yeah right yeah
no that's actually an ongoing joke
destin has fired me from fire team chat
like every month since i started he's
like you're off the show
every moment but yeah so that's how i
got into into destiny coverage and then
years years went by i continued to work
at ign but never write for them
and eventually someone i think it was
james duggan was like dude you should
just write for us
like i know you have a day job but like
you should write for us freelance and so
i tried to do that and corporate said uh
we're not going to pay you two paychecks
we're not going to pay you your day job
and then also you get a check for my gym
for writing for them
and so i quit
i quit my job after eight years and i
was like i'm gonna quit and
uh and and just work for ign and write
for for you guys and so i
you know i gave up the the six figure uh
cushy job at the other side of the
office so that i could write for them
and uh
wow yeah ever since ever since then i've
been
um covering destiny i do all of destin
destiny's reviews now because destin
really hates doing reviews he's a
he if you guys don't know destin's job
he's like the director of video
content strategy and he all he also does
a ton of previews
and cover it early access coverage he's
really good
yeah he's really good at what he does
but he hates he hates reviewing games
and he had sort of been stuck with
reviewing uh destiny because he knew the
most about it and so now
i'm the review guy for destiny and then
he gets to just
he gets to just focus on you know
hosting fire team chat and having a
million twitter followers and then i
i love that yeah
i wanna back you up because um i think
that is a tremendous
portion of your story that you kind of
glossed over and i don't i don't want to
minimize that because um at the end of
the day
like dude like to really to chase one's
dream is one thing
but to go from a stable position
where most people would say okay i can
do this and be stable and be
in one spot for the rest of my life to
kind of chase your dream
and to do what you want to do and to
make that sacrifice dude that's huge so
i got to got a commission
not a lot of people have the gumption to
do it
and um it's truly respected because it
comes from the heart comes from the
passion
and yeah wish you more success with that
that is amazing to hear something like
that
you don't hear that often so salute to
you on that that's really great yeah
i mean it took me long enough right i
worked in the same office as ign for
eight years
and it took me that long to be like i i
should be on your side of the office
like i don't know what the heck i'm
doing over here that's so
like that's so i don't know petty's not
petty is the right word but it's like
for
parent company just to say hey we don't
because i mean it's not like you're
doing it you're not like
you know in your office spreadsheet on
one screen destiny on the other you're
like you're doing that on your own time
as freelance but they're like you can't
and it's
i don't know that's just i mean they
lost they lost a good one it sounds
like someone so yeah and i was i was
high up i was director of advertising
operations like i was i was doing
a ton of their a ton of their uh stuff
not just for ign too for like a lot of
their uh
properties so um they actually said it
in the nicest way possible which is they
said like
oh yeah it'll take some time for hr to
look into this and then never
you know they did that whole thing where
they just never got back to you and
eventually i was like you know what now
you don't have to say because i'm i'm
going nowhere
i'm just going to go and write what you
want to do that's what's happening to
you on that
tremendous he got anything more because
i got one more question afterwards you
go one more right now it's like there's
there's more stuff but if you got one
sitting go for it because yeah i was
like
yeah the only question we got we gotta
have some destiny fun now
oh please unapologetic titan beam
uh yeah that's right that's the right
answer thank you very much correct
fix your face we have had a lot of
warlocks recently
and i have been outnumbered so i'm glad
i got it i got a friend here
it's been a lot of warlocks coming
through but i gotta shout out to
the titan mains best so tell me about
that why why why you know it's not
i didn't choose the titan life it chose
me
the you know titan's a tough class to be
because you
you know as the champions of last year's
um
contest to see who was the best
dominated every single day you know you
have a certain kind of
authority people kind of look up to you
hunters are at the bottom going
please like you're such a you're such a
a a role model teach me the ways and so
it's just a lot of responsibility that's
what i'm saying wow
um you know you know what it you know
what it was
it's tight that was like i'm actually
here did you did you start as
titan like yeah so straight up
yeah so uh my i tried all the classes
during the beta on ps4
no was it ps4 what console came out yeah
ps4
it was the beta for p the alpha for ps4
there was the one that was only
exclusive right
i knew i was going to get it on xbox
because all my bungee friends are on
xbox was it ps3 to ps4 because there was
no no it was not it was nice that's
eight years yeah yeah it came out 2014
which is a year after
the because i always remember the 2013
is what people refer to xbox as fall
that press conference
it's a big deal yeah yeah that was a big
deal pretty big deal kind of changed the
whole industry
yikes anyway uh yeah so uh
i played on the alpha ps4 and i was like
titans are basically master chief right
like this is a bungee game
they're like the ones who can take a
bullet they're bulkier
they don't back down and uh you know i i
like playing as hunters i think they
have
some cool abilities warlocks are
see they're if they are if they're also
in the game
he's so smooth
you know what my favorite joke was from
destiny 1 is uh
the remember in destiny 1 if i'm correct
if i'm right
warlocks were the only class to not have
an exotic boots
and i remember the joke at least with my
friends on xbox was whenever we'd get a
new guy in the party who's a warlock
would be like hey
you know why uh warlocks don't have any
exotic boots and they go why and be like
they don't need boots since they're
always getting carried
oh no i still stand behind that because
you remember back then it was it was the
res the res
that was what drew people to warlock is
like oh i forgot
it was a crutch it was a christmas for
us yeah we were definitely
a crutch of every nightfall of rain
trials you know whatever that man went
down
you know that your class is casual if
diege means your class
he is a warlock me he is
he revealed that he's a warlock man and
on it he said once you go warlock you
don't go back and
coming from a titan oh man that was a
big blow to our morale that
day a little bit
you could pray into a false god
[Laughter]
takes off his armor and there's a robe
sitting underneath and you're like what
the hell
the salute today real quick what are we
having fun with titans
yeah this is a question i always ask e i
gotta ask you though because
as much as we joke with the classes you
know you got respect for the title
what's your favorite titan npc who's
your favorite
oh well here's the thing you got a
pantheon of titans right now
that's true i will have to go with saint
14 and i think that's the obvious answer
to me titans are the weakest sub
uh class in terms of the characters
associated with them
zavala is like unapologetically the
worst member of the vanguard i think
we all agree that he's not good he's
just a shout out
yeah he's super milk toast and
uninteresting um
but yeah i say 14 always i was a
defender titan and d1
um i kind of wish there was a dedicated
subclass for that rather
you know how it kind of feels tacked on
to the current uh
void subclass for titans uh because it
was originally tacked on and then they
flushed it out a little bit more
um but yeah i've always been a defender
titan state 14
uh really identified with him i think he
was the best season
that season where you got to see that
story
that was the best non-non-main expansion
season in destiny i think i am the
greatest titan that ever lived
yes it was great yeah seeing him come
back and being able to save him and all
that stuff was dope and
his helmet is like it's one of the only
like
must-have items in the game because the
titan bubbles kind of useless without
without saint 14 helmet like if you're
not using that like
what are you doing like if you're
running that subclass that is the
anxiety
and like the imagery of that exotic as
well
like over everything in the game you
could show that to anybody who's ever
played destiny and they know exactly
what it is
icon exactly any other like warlock helm
hunter helm they might know there's a
few but that one
zero question it's fact yeah it is 100
random side note uh titan question i
gotta ask you guys why does
um my boy doesn't get doesn't seem to
get much love in titan lore no one seems
to like our iron lord brother
uh salad oh yeah yeah
i never heard anyone everyone says
shacks say 14.
yeah nobody says about it no one says
yeah saladin i wonder why saladin is one
of the only
um one of the only titans who really has
gotten a lot of backstory to him he
basically got his own dlc
right which which all of the other
titans i have either
always been in the game as a vendor or
they got like a side thing like state 14
got a little side thing
but lord saladin was right in the center
of
of his own mainline expansion i think
that that
hasn't really happened i think the
reason people forget about him is just
because
they turned him into a vendor and he's
kind of not interesting anymore and i
kind of hate that
because he was super dope
oh my god like yeah the fire x when he
did that you've got him with siva coming
out and that open the cinematic with him
and the wolves
and of course i have huskies so the
wolves i was like dude you're like
you're like my guy here and then as you
said it perfectly he's like now he's
just a vendor who shows up every so
often probably too often but
i just wish they yeah i feel from
because i agree i think when his
introduction was so
impactful and i mean look iron wrote
podcast started
because the rise of iron you know saying
like that's how much it i'm like damn i
want to play zavala so
it's interesting to see yeah his just
being reduced to a vendor
and you know i'm just sad like i want to
see him
involved more in in the narrative you
know at least especially when events
happen
he doesn't really change his dialogue
much you know and
i just want to see him kind of react to
what's going on in the world
you know yeah yeah that would be cool if
they gave him something to do
or maybe brought him back even for like
a season pass like make a story about
his character or
bring siva back or something but if you
would have asked me who my favorite
titan was in destiny who actually shows
up in the game
in you know in in the year rise of iron
was the thing i would have said lord
salad and no hands down because
that's like that's like obvious because
jax is shax is great he's got i'm a
crucible main so like for me
i spend a lot of time i spend a lot of
time with shacks
um but yeah saladin saladin's amazing
he's a really good character that i wish
they used better
this is a gripe i've had in destiny
forever it's like all these great
characters
all these concepts for stories and they
don't use any of it they just let it
just sit on the shelf i mean you got i
mean and dakota just said i cora hasn't
had a look in quite a long time
and you've got so many dangling threads
you've got the uldren story line of
which we're like is that
is that actually going to happen there's
like rumors and questions and is this
icon
actually going to be a thing and paul
tessie's like kind of nailing it down
that actually might be fairly close but
either way you look at all of these
things that we've been through there's
so much that still as you said
unused stories that are so set up with a
lot of potential to them
yeah we have a lot of on like right now
we've got
whatever the heck's going on with
sabbath then we've got
uh the darkness plot line and the fact
that they're coming which
and the shadow keep ending where you
meet the darkness and it looks like you
and all that stuff spoiler alert if
you're
listening to the destiny podcast
yeah so you know that that whole thing
is a that you like you got it right the
older and solve is a
loose plotline thread um even even
stuff like the curse in the dreaming
city
like did we solve that like what is
going on what's going on yeah
i mean i keep wondering that one
specifically it was like because
as soon as they said what destinations
were leaving and what's staying the fact
that the dreaming city is still staying
we have savathune coming
there might be i'm my hunch has like has
been always
like if they're gonna like rehash a
destination like they did with
cosmodrome
but then bring a new one in to give you
like two new destinations for the
expansions but not make one quite as
much work
like dreadnought with like a dreaming
city tie-in or something like that to
get a little bit of story through there
and if savithoon comes and
that's the like the sabbathun you know
death battery that's going on and all
that stuff like
i i'm with you as like i've spent way
too much time in the shattered throne
just because
like i worked on dungeon videos and
stuff in there for me and i'm just like
at some point i feel really sorry for
these people every week and i did a
senate videos for like a year the
ascendant challenges
like every time i go talk to petra i'm
like here we are again
like and i'm just like i feel sorry for
an entire year i'm like and it hasn't
changed for like
we're going into year four and i'm going
i don't think you're going to get any
better news yet
mm-hmm yeah and that's really that's
weird
i think if they do redo the dreaming
city they'll probably just like
keep the map the same same and then
they'll add like a throne world
version of it because you know we're
definitely going to go into sabbath and
throne world like that has been
sort of hinted at in the lore and the
fact that we're getting pulled into an
unknown throne world every week and this
uh this season of arrivals that sort of
thing so i think we're probably going to
end up
i would be interested to see if we'll
get a throne world as a destination in
destiny like something on your map that
you go to
uh it'll probably most more likely than
that be like the raid and maybe it'll be
in strikes and that sort of stuff but
do you do you guys happen to know whose
throne world we're going into
in like the strike that's in the
dreaming city and stuff like that like
oh the i don't know
yeah the corrupted strike like i don't
really know who's i know that in
shattered throne you're entering mara
solves throne world right when it's all
destroyed kings fall you enter oryx's
throne world
i'm not really sure whose throne world
we're in in the dreaming city
but i assume that it's sabbath we gotta
go bikes back we have to have bath back
on again yeah no [ __ ]
yeah we need to call up the bike yeah we
gotta go buy if that's a bike call
milan games we're gonna have to call
them get them in because yeah yeah i am
not sure yeah
it's a good question i yeah or somebody
in the comments i see said the ascendant
plane i'm not sure if the ascendant
plane is just like
a generic catch all for like throne
worlds but yeah
to me they seem an awful lot similar the
two
right yes upside down from the stranger
things so yeah
and that was like perfectly timed so
that's like that's all you can think of
too
yeah it's like they always mention the
ascendant plane and you do the ascended
challenges
but yeah it's like they have that exact
same look when you go to mars for
shattered throne i'm like
we're talking the same very dark drab
black and white you know monochrome look
throughout the entire thing
and yet very specifically mara saab's
throne with all of that going on
sabbath hopefully at some point but
dreaming city the ascendant plane always
seems weird and you're always talking to
what's the little floating poland i
don't know what he's doing in there
either maybe it's his
yeah totally that's another one that's
like his that's like you know what it is
tolland is just
uh osiris instead of being in the
infinite forest he's in the ascendant
plane and it's like the exact same arc
it's like hey there
once was this cool person and now he is
in this other world and he focuses on
on just that it's like the same thing
yeah good point good point
quick question um just curious uh
top three raids for all of the french
parades
are we going there see that man's place
so this is let's just get this out of
the way because i don't think it's gonna
surprise anyone but my three favorite
raids are all
in destiny 1. um i
i yeah i mean destiny 2 is a great game
i think the shooting mechanics are
awesome
uh better than destiny 1 but
they put a lot of time in those raids
with the exception of crota's end which
i
kind of think is bad i think it's bad um
but that's okay you're winning back with
your friends here you're winning
right now you're back home baby we
forgive the tight slander now
i love i love hunters and warlocks but
i'm duty-bound as a titan to
to give them flack anytime i can um
anyway uh
yeah i think um
in order bolt of glass
so oh
are both so good um
bring it home yeah i'm gonna go with
king's fall and wrath of the machines
because and that's an order of their
release minus crota's end which is sort
of like a
a middle one but um for me vault of
glass
it it's it kind of it changed so much in
the gaming world i remember
destiny came out and it kind of it kind
of went over like a wet fart was my
memory of it like it
nobody really cared except for the
people who really were getting into it
for some reason but at the beginning it
was sort of
but i remember a month later it was a
full month before vaulted glass came out
talk to you and when that happened
that game changed it was
unreal and i remember i stayed up all
night the night that it came out and i
was playing it all through the weekend
with this group of people that i'm still
friends with on xbox live sometimes i
talk to them like
you always remember who you did like
vaulted glass with
like crota's end maybe not but walter
glass like you remember those people
yeah i mean it was great obviously it
had some bugs and people figured out you
know you can stand far away and just use
icebreaker to kill the first boss or
even just push it off the edge and you
can push the final boss off the edge but
it took a people a while to figure that
out because we were new to raids we
hadn't kind of figured out all the
tricks yet right
absolutely and uh you know crota i
remember the first weekend we were
playing that raid we were already
pulling out our ethernet cables so i
just remember
that's you know that's my recollection
of those uh those
kind of uh those those raids but yeah
vaulted glass was was just really well
designed
um it has one of my favorite lines in
destiny which is guardians make their
own fate
i mean that that that little that flavor
text i think they call it
so good it's such a satisfying so i
don't know why they don't put that in
more because it's
now it's sort of used as like an
information feed like you're yes
you know getting updates from like cnn
like it's like
put some stuff in there you know like i
want to see some cool
uh nuggets of information yeah
absolutely
but yeah that was really cool and then
um you know krotozen
just they added everybody was a bullet
sponge and every encounter was just can
you kill a lot of things that have a lot
of health that was my name was probably
no in defensive crota
i like i like to dive down it was
true kind of of cool that's true that's
like the very beginning yeah very
beginning it's kind of cool the very
beginning is cool in the very
end and how you kill the boss it's cool
because my recollection of that whole
and the music counter
the music yeah
like it's just like every single
track is a banger in destiny yeah i mean
i was i was at bungie hq with a bunch of
outlets and we were just talking for
like two hours about
all of the good music and destiny and
what our favorite songs were
and all this stuff and yeah you can get
into a rabbit hole that alone but uh
yeah um for me king's fall
the reason that wins over wrath of the
machines is
purely because of the lore and the final
boss fight
oryx was the best villain destiny's ever
had actually and
my biggest problem with destiny is that
they've not
had one villain that we're fighting
against this whole time they create a
villain and we know him for about six
hours before we kill whoever that was
yeah
shout out to the worm god we killed in
the strike in one minute
killed in a strike yeah well that's the
thing is that they they kind of and i
think it's a retcon i don't think they
had this plan from the beginning but
they
brought zoll back and we're like oh we
he tricked you into killing him isn't
destiny a good game uh you know and that
sort of thing but
because you remember they brought him
back yeah the secret yeah yeah
and they were like oh yeah maybe maybe
he was just toying with us the whole
time but
i kind of hate that we haven't had an
overarching villain what what i thought
i reviewed destiny 2
vanilla as well and what i was hoping is
that you know destiny 2 would last
three years or however long it lasted
just like destiny one did
and that gaul would be the villain for
all of those years yeah maybe we would
do
different stuff paul was cool he was
cool and he had a lot of potential but
his biggest problem was that
they turned him into like goku in the
last shot
and then he got killed and it was just
like what the hell man like it could
have been dope
so i mean chat's basically saying like
the only other one right now is sabathun
but it's like
she doesn't feel real yeah she feels
like
um you know how like in
you know how like there's some
properties where like you only know
about characters from like the
uh expanded universe comic book yeah
like the
novel that nobody knew about like you
know bucky from
from halo like you know about him
because he was in you know odst
or whatever stuff like that she she
feels like she's part of the expanded
universe
and you know she's this big bad villain
who we've never seen
we you only know anything about her if
you've read the grimoire and are nerd
like me
yeah she's been alluded to forever but i
would guarantee you that 99.7 percent of
the destiny community has
no idea who sabbath is yeah uh and
and you know they would probably be like
oh yeah their name wasn't a strike or
something like that
like that's the that's the farthest
thing that's like her that the names
have a thunder's been on like enemies
and yet savage
song i was like i mean prescott said it
she's like
sauron of lord of the rings it's like
it's the
far away threat that in theory is
terrifying
in potential but we don't have a clue
because we've never seen it in action
someone's actually being nice to it
because sauron at least you get to see
him kick ass in the opening scene
right you know yeah
[Music]
it would be like if if at the beginning
of lord of the rings you get to see like
sauron's brother kill a bunch of people
and then they spend the rest of the
movie talking about song
that's good that's actually good though
that's actually accurate that's actually
accurate
yeah yeah you see oryx be badass and
then you uh you know
savathon is just low-key that we never
get to see
in defense of saboteur and you you're
absolutely right yeah i mean i
they haven't done enough i felt to truly
build a shout out to gam in the chat
riding for savannah it's gonna be
interesting satisfied when we finally
get her and which cream though
they've been building her she's taking
it true yeah what was the strike e
that they brought in this last one i
don't know if it was a playstation
exclusive daddy bro
festering core i felt i learned
more when everest jumped in on the
transmission and was really talking
about her deceptive nature and the
things that she tries to do to
manipulate things and how we wouldn't
know her move
like i felt that you're losing that
strike
yeah i'm like that one had a pretty
short lifespan that said
yeah it did yeah i remember i
yeah so that's that's my problem is like
destiny is
i i say this all the time on fire team
chat it's one of the best
and 10 of the worst games i've ever
played um
and you're not wrong like
the the problem with destiny's
storytelling is that
is that they have so much good material
to work with and they don't use a whole
lot of it and savathon is absolutely one
of those areas in my opinion where they
can do a better job
and i'm really hoping that over this
next year they'll take some time to sort
of carve her out because
i have a feeling she's going to die in a
year right like she's going to die in
the raid or at the end of the story in a
year
and that'll be over and maybe they're
wrapping up destiny because the year
after that is lightfall and
and who knows you know what what that's
gonna mean for the destiny world
um but i do i just hope we get payoff i
really hope there's a plan i feel like
there isn't a plan in destiny's
storytelling and they're kind of just
winging it uh
and they do a really good job because if
they are winging it but
i just this is one of those things we
almost have to have like
it's like that that that scene in uh the
last crusade where
indy has to uh take that first step
it's a leap of faith of like god i hope
that i'm not wasting these
six years i've been playing destiny and
learning so much about it through the
grimoire and i really hope that there's
some payoff here and uh
yeah i mean bungie's a company if
there's any company to rise to the
challenge
mm-hmm it's bungie oh it's possible
absolutely yeah yeah i mean that's one
that's the thing it's like i'm with you
is like we have witch queen setting up
potential of savathune you have
lightfall
and we've got these like darkness powers
coming on i'm like
you're putting a whole lot of cool stuff
in all of our heads that could be real
please do something like you have
marasov like she's queen with her own
ascendant realm as well of like her
brother who's here you got petra like
just that section alone between mara
eris
and savathun with what's going on with
those three and that weird triangle
and then you've also got well i cannot
remember the single sock lady
emissary oh emissary yeah the emissary
and all of the nine like
nine jesus she he he got me on the same
the like the one so
like she's like yeah it's like she's got
one different colored foot
absolutely
i was going to say the nine or another
thing where like they're in the game
explicitly and i most people have no
idea what they are
i know because i've looked up the
grimoire and done a bunch of research
because i was like what the hell are the
nine
and then they did that one they did the
uh the
uh dungeon recently right and the whole
thing was
you know finally figure out who the nine
are and you have no
idea who the nine are still here so yeah
it didn't make any sense so just real
quick just to recap we're going to
finish up the rate thing um
again so you got vault we got king oh
shout out to fukado who actually made a
good point about vault he was like he
strongly believes destiny wouldn't be
where destiny was if that experience
didn't happen
i actually didn't 100 i didn't agree
with him
yeah it's like that did because destiny
was like what are we doing and then
bam that like yeah changed the idea
forever
29s oh so much because i was waiting on
my house
i was a forever 29 i never got the boots
for the titan from that raid
never ever in destiny and i did it every
single week
wow uh you know i was one of those guys
where the drop rate just didn't work out
for me
but uh the that that whole idea of being
a forever 29 and reaching max power and
the
chase for it and the aspiration that
wouldn't exist without vaulted glass
because
that end game the end game was vaulted
glass in the at the end of the day back
then there was no trials there were no
other raids that was the end game
so yeah that was that king's fall for me
that raid is sort of
mediocre it but the thing i it's
mediocre in
parts but the on the whole it's really
solid it's all boss fights it's like
boss rush you know you're just fighting
boss after boston oh
cool yeah they all have unique they all
have dope armor
and yes the ogre is whatever but you
know
they all at least the ogre looks cool
he's got that cool spawn animation
but for me i day one that raid
i worked so hard to be one of the first
people to beat that raid we're gonna
have that discussion
i know you're gonna say the nine they're
celestial bodies
dude it does yeah anyway
king king's fall uh is uh
that when that that moment where he came
up oh
the final boss so epic that was like
okay this is awesome and it made the
entire journey worth it because i was
banging my head against the wall for
like
14 hours before we got to the final boss
encounter where orcs actually came out
and i just remember i hadn't i had not
been watching other streams i had not
been
cheating at all and when i saw it i i
just stood there
for the entire first wipe i was just
standing there looking at him like
what the hell and one of my teammates
just
he you could hear him take off his
headset and screaming from another room
like he was just running around his
house like
ah you know you just hear that in the
background
that was great and then you got to say
yeah so that's that's number two for me
and then wrapping machines is number
three because it has the single best
encounter
in any raid which is uh the uh siege
engine
see jinjin shut up it talks about
is it might be a first yeah siege engine
is the best encounter in any raid
it is super fun it's very unique
it is unlike any other encounter in any
raid
and it has the world's best ending which
is you just ride it to hell like you
take it over and then you just sort of
it's just it's so metal man it's
such a such a good encounter i remember
getting to that point on day one i day
one to that rate as well
and getting up to that point was really
demoralizing it was like oh you know
where i got to as well and and it was
just like
it was totally different for me as well
as like first time was just like
what the hell are we doing what's my man
what's my shout out to mixes the one
that always the
he always messes it up the the the
fallen that does so you gotta
you gotta get him before he does
something with the engine parts and all
that stuff
it'll be like mixes did this and i'm
like the game always tells you in the
corner
like shout out to him but yeah that was
that was a unique
encounter and the engine parts did move
it right yeah
very very just the fact that you take
over the boss
and then you like use it to kill all the
bad guys and then drive it off a cliff
like
i remember when we got through that
encounter it reinvigorated all of us
like the whole party was sort of getting
fatigued
and we got to that point and we were
just like all right that was so cool
not only am i ready for the rest of this
raid but i can't wait to do it again
i can't wait to play that again now not
having to figure out how to do it that
was just so great
absolutely slow man tremendous history
man
boys certified boy oh yeah no that's
that's pretty epic right there he's
qualified i think he's qualified to
review destiny
oh yeah you think so it's a whole bit
i'll give them i'll give them
i'll give them the check mark of uh
compliance there yeah
doing well doing quite well what's going
on in the world destiny man
nothing nothing major you know no uh
next gin for starters cause you know
speaking of a guy who works in the games
industry now this man
is potentially gonna dodge some of it
but be around the chaos that is the next
gen lunch
that's right uh we got a little little
preview before but we actually finally
got confirmation of what we're going to
get in the next generation of destinies
so for sirius x and ps5
we've got 4k 60 which everybody's been
waiting on
and i think more important people could
have played playing on a peanut
or like with you know like blinders on
but they got the field of view slider
i think that's probably what everybody
is the most excited about they could be
like
you can give me 14 40 240 hertz i don't
care but give me the field of view i
think is what everybody on console has
been waiting for
faster load times crosston all that
stuff's good
series s is going to be 1080 60 same
stuff with field of view
i think the field of view is the one
that i've seen more people lose their
mind about so
curious too same here if you are pumped
excited do you think
are they missing anything for next-gen
what are you guys looking at
uh i think uh this is awesome i
i sort of wonder if some of the consoles
could do more than 60 fps
especially if they were in a performance
mode where they were 1080 i would like
to be able to make that decision i mean
i think destin plays in 1440 or 1080 or
something he does not play in 4k
so that he can play at 120 fps um i
think console players should be able to
have that option now that they
uh have the power to do this you know
before it was sort of like
they're just trying to get to 30. you
know they're they don't have the
privilege to like
you know you're not going to lower it to
720p so that you can run a few extra
frames
but yeah so so i i think that that would
be great but
i think the real like the lead that is
being buried in all this is like
how good it's gonna be for people who
buy the series s
because honestly having playing in 1080p
i think it's something like 70 of gamers
do not have a 4k display
actually and the fact that you can play
at 1080p
at 60fps with fov sliders which is like
pretty much in the past only been a
pc specific feature ever um
i think it's great man for 300 bucks you
can play
a really really high-end version of
destiny and you could probably max out
the tv that you have because
realistically
monitors running more than 60 fps
is pretty rare right or it's pretty
pretty hard to get tvs it's like unheard
of like
the tvs that can do 4k 120 fps are like
few and far between yeah like unless you
get them right now
yeah there's like shout outs i have one
yeah yeah so you've got one too yeah you
got that lgbc
amazing yeah i mean if driving you
finish i don't know if you're still
going
that's it i'm done i'm excited for this
i think it's great fov slider is
absolutely the biggest
uh the biggest of the the things to be
happy about yeah man this is
this is tremendous i mean let's just get
it let me get the negative out the way
first
you know um waking up obviously the
vampire to the news
the first thing that hit me was december
8th
so you know for me uh the show i'll give
you the history is that
you know as a console guy that's just my
history i'm
you know born and raised i'm gonna
control the guy he doesn't just what i
do
but the thing that hit me i was i had it
all mentally prepared
chad i was like yo series x drops
beyond light everyone's laughing at the
xbox and you're like oh xbox doesn't
have an exclusive i'm like
destiny's there at launch i'm i'm good
you know what i'm saying so game pass
i'm like oh this it was like the
coronation
cognito's coming home i'm telling my
whole xbox beauty
and then you slipped on the banana peel
on the way up yeah i'm like november
10th we there baby because i told my
clan
i was like look you know when he showed
me tapped me to the darkness
i'm not sorry i'm not evil pc life
i was corrupted those frames that field
of view
i was like i'm not doing 30 frames ever
again
i just can't and it's just like playing
it is like
playing in molasses and i'm just like i
can't do it
so i've been over here on pc you know
eighty percent of my clan still on xbox
i
formed you know the clan still exists
but it's about 20 of us over here
so this was my excited time so to see it
the december 8th did it hit me
i was like damn i gotta wait a month and
i was really looking forward to
showcasing the series x and my tv and
all the other stuff
but when i read the details and i saw a
field of view
i'll be right with you i never thought
they would do it
because in my opinion i was like i
wasn't sure console guys have always
been and i don't mean disrespectful
they've always been babied like
it's always like we're not going to give
you these extensive features we don't
want to confuse you
you know last gen we got a frame rate in
a performance mode which was big for the
next generation console refreshes
but i never knew that would happen
because my thing is i was willing to
accept
no filter i was telling my guys like
don't get your hopes up too high for fov
you know look we're gonna have nvme
drives you're gonna be loading into the
strikes and the raids all fast
you're gonna be in orbit chilling you
know what i'm saying you're gonna have
that 60 frames you're gonna understand
why i left you once you see 60 you're
gonna
understand you're gonna be oh my god
this is a different game god i get it
now
i get it but to have the fov there's so
many now of my pc guys
that were like yo i'd come over there
but if they ain't no fov cog
i'm not going the xbox you know what i'm
saying over there so to see this this is
to me that's worth the wait that's worth
the wait
i'm willing to psych so yes uh clan i'll
be on pc for another month
i'll be here you know i'll be rooting
you guys on you know what i said
well once y'all bring that 60 and that
fov
bam your man right back home so but this
was just a tremendous salute to them and
like you said uh travis um
series s man i mean 1080p 60 like you
said a lot of people don't have 4k
monitors you know for 300 dollars you
get in the game game pass
and there's shout out to playstation 5
4k 62. so everything's going they're
getting
fov everything is lit like this is such
a cool thing and then obviously
cross-generational the saves you know
xbox yeah matchbox guy that's gonna be
big you know i i have some questions
about the cross-generational thing which
are
you know right now i have an xbox one x
and when i load into a strike i hang out
for 90 seconds while i wait for the guy
with an og xbox one to load in
and i know on pc you have to do that as
well if people have older
cpus it takes them longer or no it's
drives right yeah
usually whatever it is old drives yeah
yeah drives that takes them oil to get
in
um then i i'm wondering how
wide that gap is going to get if you're
on a series x versus an og
xbox live that is a very different
experience
and you're like i see that guy i
literally can't see him
he's not even on the screen for
matchmaking there has to be
i hope there has to be some priority
given to people that are on
the next gen platform versus the old one
because
i see that being really uh
troubling if we're doing that and then
also having 60 fps in crucible over
somebody who's on the xbox one that's
going to be nasty because i don't know
anybody on pc who plays crucible at a
any compatible kind of competitive level
who has a 30 fps
uh computer running running 30 less
fewer than 60 frames that's pretty rare
uh so i can see that being and
thankfully it works in my favor i mean
i've got my series x pre-ordered it's
gonna be here year one so i'm definitely
gonna be dunking on some people who are
on 30 fps
but it just seems pretty toxic
okay there you go i was gonna say real
quick and i i'll let you go
is that i'm actually surprised another
reason why too is that
again console is such a controlled space
right
and one of the biggest fears that we got
last gen we were like
would these mid-generation refreshes
even allow that frame disparity if
from a competitive standpoint and i
remember there were times where bungie
was questioned microsoft was questioned
a lot of people questioned like
would you allow a 60 frames guy go
against 30 frames guy and all that stuff
so to me this is them full on like i was
surprised how bold this movie is like yo
we're allowing all these different
ecosystems to intermingle
and hey it is what it is kind of thing
so
selfishly i don't mind because i already
know what side i'm on
but it is it is a departure from the
safe nature of console
consoles traditionally tend to shy away
from this and this is them really kind
of embracing especially with fov but
okay
i'm gonna let you know i know y'all know
i mean that's like a huge piece of this
is you've got people that are used to
this on pc
because i mean you've got people who are
buying 360 hertz monitors for 1080p
games and stuff like csgo versus like
hey what's cs go let me turn it on they
like can't even blink fast enough to get
killed so
pc is used to that and as you said
console has been console
is you buy a typically set package and
not a whole lot of options in there
now as you said the next generation
gives you the switch of performance and
things and now they are going to have
potentially like three modes
i think for me one of the biggest ones
for the two powerful consoles
series x and ps5 they're both going to
be powerful they're doing 4k 60.
i would love to have seen them do like
either
1440 120 or 120 like
because there's some people who are like
hey if i can buy a monitor and it's like
it's a kid in a room but maybe he ca
is able to get like 1080p monitors at
high refresh rates they're not that
expensive at this point so the entry at
that level isn't terrible like you try
and go 4k 144 hertz
you might as well buy a new car but like
there's some
like you may as well buy a tv honestly
with some of those that's almost the
same price
but if you're gonna go 1080p and you're
like i just want the fast
refresh rate it'd be nice to be like hey
i got the ps5
for each but i can go you know 144 hertz
or whatever
that's the piece that i would like to
see them go between and give the option
for i don't know if that's
later to give more resolution choices
but i mean
the field of view is a big one but the
the frame rate i think some people would
happily be like i don't need to see 4k
if i can get the faster refresh rate
there's a lot of people who would love
to see that one
and then as you also said as well travis
you said like the loading times you're
going
you know old xbox one regular ps4
spinning hard drive
to nvme next gen what is
what is and then also as like the field
of view slider and as literally i'm like
hey i can see
this much there's a guy over here who
where and the guy's like but one has to
turn just to see him
much less like yeah he's over there on
my right i got him it's like in the
communication almost in a raid and
even in pve activities it's like you're
gonna be able to pull some of those
people through but that's not going to
be the optimal way to play and it's like
they're really going to start to
potentially see here there's going to be
videos comparing the differences of like
what are you missing out on if you don't
have a
new console this and you're just like
how much more you can see and stuff is
going to be very interesting i'll be
curious to see
comparisons between really old consoles
and the brand new ones like right next
to each other and it's just going to be
like
yeah like somebody rub wax on your
screen or something like that it's going
to be pretty terrible that
that vaseline yeah that's what i was
thinking of yeah i mean
i agree with you i think that um look i
don't want to
i'm not a developer you know so i don't
want to disrespect
you but i i am in my heart i would
assume if we're going to say
the playstation 5 is the equivalent of
maybe a 2060 super and the
you know the xbox series equivalent of a
2080 you know what i'm saying
then really got to get that xbox in
there don't you go for it
no i'm not trying to i'm not even trying
to counsel i'm not serious i'm not even
trying to comment
like i'm just saying like um no i'm just
saying like one would think
right that both of them could do a 1440p
120 hertz kind of joint and i think
this is this this is i think this is
this is my opinion so forgive me bungie
if i
this is how i feel bungie being safe and
saying look we're going to cap you here
you know what i'm saying and then maybe
later down the road we revisit because
the
same reason why i'm saying this is
because in my opinion
i would have sworn the xbox one x
would have been able to do the 60 frames
on the med gen
refresh and the fact that we could and
the fact that the series
x on launch on november 10th because we
all know
with the brute forcing that the series x
is doing right now with back compat
is forcing games with unlockable frame
rates to
get to higher frame rates so to me that
shows me
i'm again inferring i'm not a developer
that bungie is
locking frame rates for stability
standpoint thus
when you get a series x you play beyond
light you're not going over 30 frames
we know that series x can do that game
more than 30 frames
so that's why i feel this is again daddy
bungee
kind of putting that cap you know not
what to mess around with things on the
stability standpoint to go over frame
rates
because i too like e sin would love a
120
frames 1440 or 1080p mode if possible
you know what i'm saying that would be
another cool option to give gamers but
don't get me wrong i'm not complaining
i'm happy about what's going on be
getting our field of view but there's
just something i was thinking about when
he was talking yeah and that's just one
of those maybe as more tvs like right
now there's not a lot of tvs doing 4k
120 hertz but
some are doing 120 hertz at lower
resolutions but again as you one of you
guys said it's
not common as that becomes more of an
adoption thing and they may look at like
you know statistics of steam and see how
many people have those it's like
when those numbers start climbing up
that you know higher refresh rate
displays and everything are in more
people's hands
they might put the development time into
it for something like say witch queen
if it's made more adoption rate over the
course of the next year right now
i it just may not be there yeah i think
that's actually exactly what's happening
i think it's not
uh bungie saying hey we want to control
what you're doing or we want to
cap our game lower than what your
console can do i think it has more to do
with
uh creating an ecosystem that isn't
confusing for
console gamers because console gamers
and i count myself among this because i
hate fiddling with my pc i have to do it
a lot
um i hate uh we we don't want to have to
deal with that stuff that's why we're on
console and so
if you plug a if you try to run a game
at 120 fps and your
console says you can do it but your tv
isn't having it the frames drop
i've done that on pc and it runs at like
24 frames per second or something like
that when it when it when it's
plugged into a monitor that can display
it uh people who play on xbox and
playstation they
do not play on monitors by and large and
so tvs that exist that can run more than
60 frames
are pretty rare and i think that yeah
right
and i think that enabling it in a way
where it was
user friendly to say hey your tv doesn't
support more than 60 fps we need to go
back
i think that's the real problem i think
they're they're sort of waiting for t
we're kind of waiting for tvs to catch
up with what our
displays can now do like our xboxes our
playstations so a valid point and it
into your point which you're absolutely
right is that they have to
listen bungie we know they look at their
data you know realistically
you know who really besides me and a few
others who really has that setup the
majority of console gamers don't have
that setup
so to put the resources into that mode
at this point when it's early in the gen
definitely answers that question so i do
i agree with your assessment i mean
series
s and is potentially the one as ever
being kind of like even i see um
uh what paris he's always talking about
the css is the dark horse of the
consoles because it's like
that's the one a lot of people are going
to get that's not the big beefy one
going for everything that's the one
people just want to get 1080p 60
for their normal tvs and that's what it
may be for a little two or three years
from now when things start to really get
adapting some of that adoption gets
higher
maybe a different picture whatever
happens after lightfall that may be
where we're going like okay
all tvs do all crazy things now let's
talk good point
good point no you're right open my eyes
uh but outside of that that's a big one
of course we knew that 12 was coming and
what was the one thing everybody was
waiting on when the hell are we gonna
get to raid
and we finally got to figure it out oh
you finally got an
answer and that's like one of the
biggest things so for one that's a great
answer
yeah it's it it's definitely a a pretty
damn good answer
definitely one more favorable from what
i was seeing some in the past so i'm
glad we're kind of at this point but
yeah
saturday november 21st 10 a.m pacific
that is the world's first raids raid
date a couple things we'll know
contest mode will cap all players at 20
below power for each encounter for 24
hours
kind of favorite contest would be there
artifact power will be disabled during
contest mode that's a big point of
discussion we'll get to a minute
and then 12 30 power is your team's goal
to be at the top
cap for all the encounters so you can
get to 12 30 theoretically you would
have
as much level advantage as you can for
every single encounter anything beyond
12 30
even for the final fight you're gonna
get no benefits out of it
so starting there the dates and just the
details about it
thoughts opinions cognito or travis
travis
has a hey we got a hand raised oh yeah
that's my hand raised because i'm so
happy with what they're doing so
a few things here i think we can all
agree
because i i'm sure some of you guys have
at one point in your destiny
life tried to try to at least complete
the raid on the first day
right um the worst part of that
experience
is not the rate itself even though that
can be really painful
it's the process leading up to it where
you have to kill yourself
to get to the power that you need to
actually play the raid
it's bad it's not fun nobody enjoys it
it's not
and then and then the people who exploit
get rewarded
by getting more power and going to the
rate at an unfair level
and it's just it's just always
unpleasant so
we're talking about this on fire team
chat which uh streaming now
um
what we talked about was like last week
we said what would be your ideal
situation
don't make the power crazy just cap how
much you can bring with you like they've
been doing in grand master nightfalls
they did that right release it
well after the game comes out at least a
week so that we don't have to do that
sprint as crazily
as we've had to in the past and we can
start talking about who our teams are
gonna be and kind of strategizing that
sort of thing
they did that um as somebody who's
reviewing the game i reviewed shadow
keep and i had
three days to get raid ready and i had
to write my review the fourth day
that is not fun it is not healthy and i
think for those of us who
the rate is four right the rate is only
played by what like five percent of the
community i think they said
and and that that those people are the
people who are going to take time off
work and full commit and so
i think the fact that you maybe don't
have to do that now
is awesome um and you know i'm going to
get some more time to capture footage
and
do more stuff for my review and then
that final saturday that will be my last
day i'll
beat the raid or at least get to the
final encounter so i can see all the
content
and then i'll i'll be off to the races
and be able to write and
so for me personally it's great i think
for the community it's great
most importantly it gets rid of that
terrible terrible terrible pre-rate
grind
that just has never gone smoothly in my
opinion so
and then also saturday mornings i mean
perfect that's like the chef's kit
that's the cherry on top of this amazing
new sundae so
this is all great yeah yeah i mean uh
you know the i think
you know i i wouldn't i know this is a
point of contention to you know a lot of
hot
topic on twitter with ian others
shout out to addict but um yeah look man
i think this is great i think this is
great i i think
you know that the following week is more
than enough time
i think saturday is perfect because
again you know
most people got to work you know to do
something during that time i always felt
was a little awkward
so i loved that decision obviously
contest rules are there
and um again to ease defense because i
know he's on the side of pushing things
back
you know i do agree with him in the
first
week is too much because you're just now
experienced
you're almost speed balling through and
sometimes you don't
get to appreciate the meal whether it be
the campaign and you're just so
light heavy right you just you know like
like whatever whatever and i think
sometimes it it is a bit much that that
first week
so i think too i think that's i honestly
i think this
from in my opinion should be the cadence
going forward you know what i'm saying
not the first week of release
you get to that second reset and then
even think about that friday's always a
trials day because i think like you just
have like trials in the raid on the same
day
you know saying you know everyone's
going to do the world's first but i
think that's the perfect spot
the only thing i want to defend the
hardcore raider part which
i'm in the defense of this you know kind
of two-week cadence as opposed to
pushing it out even further
is that we have to admit contest mode is
a big thing for bungie
you know what i'm saying they get all
eyes on the game it blows up twitch from
an engagement standpoint it's just cool
you know what i'm saying just
you know people get the raid jackets you
get your championship belt and
you know i remember watching you know
the uh what is it the last wish
uh raid you know uh finals that was
pretty awesome that kind of stuff
and it's really cool to see obviously
you know i feel
contest mode is the ultimate you know
nullifier to keep things bouncing
letting us know hey 12 30 this is what
it's going to be
you know and from that point on so we
have to remember this my last point
this is for the hardcore also right
so we have to respect the people who
want to put in that
work and they want to know life if they
get the maximum power cap
to try to achieve this goal and the only
kind of argument i say is for
people who don't want it to be two weeks
is that
you know you don't have to raid right
then
like you could wait like you you don't
you know this is for the world's first
guys
right these are for the i listen i've
tried i'm
i'm there every day one but i ain't i
ain't that talented and i got enough but
i'm there you know saying for my team
but we
will get to a certain you know usually
about a second a third it kind of
usually breaks us
and then we're like all right you can't
figure this out you know we're gonna
have to take two before people start
fighting with each other
but at the end of the day you know this
is
a cool prestigious thing and i like to
see
the hardcore community get behind it and
yeah that's listen i think this
i love this date man i really do
saturday you know a week after
i'm all for it so i'll give it to e
cause i know this is a
hot button topic for him no it wasn't
for me or at least i didn't think it was
going to be
until my twitter yeah until something
happened on twitter yesterday i won't
get it all that but no i was like for me
um somebody did point out like honestly
for me if it was one more saturday
granted that's thanksgiving so that if
the holiday wasn't there but if this was
like a
september release but if it was one more
saturday still would be fine with me
because now for somebody like you like
reviewing a game i could see like you're
like
kind of need to put a bow on the very
end of this thing so depending on when
that comes out you might have to do
that's where you guys would be like well
here's all the content i played through
most of it we're waiting for the raid
for like three weeks
do you do do you do one of your like
review in progress or anything like that
pending raid type thing
i mean i can see some of those but
something like division two when they
tried to release theirs i don't even
remember how long after that came out
that that raid finally came out
that was way too long so obviously
that's too long but also as you guys
have said
the three to four day crazy grind don't
sleep 72 hours of
just absolute insanity in my mind that's
not fun for anybody and for me whether
it's like
11 days or 18 days for like the next
saturday if it's not thanksgiving since
that's a holiday
that would be the point where for me it
allows more people to get to the grind
and it allows more people to if they
have full-time jobs you know they play
in the evenings they get a couple hours
they get more time on the weekends
that's their time to really kind of put
in the heavy grinding even if they're
going to do it
that just gives more people a chance to
get into even a day one race
blind because a lot of people if you pay
attention to the destiny community it's
hard to see
some things in a blind state if they
don't see it on the first day
but if they're not able to get into it
because they have a busy world but one
more week helps them
contest modifier helps a ton because
you could be what 1260 power level going
in like three weeks later but
everybody's still gonna be at that same
level when you jump into the raid so
two weeks three weeks like to me that's
not it doesn't need to be two months
because then you do kind of lose some
relevancy and there's
seasons but for me it was like i mean i
put a poll on twitter it's like i don't
have the biggest audience but of 175
votes
90 of the people said anywhere from
seven to
like 18 to 30 days like there was only
about 10 of people that said three to
four days
so it doesn't look like a decent
majority are like i want a little time
for one like bungie always gives us a
good amount of content
but we also don't get to typically enjoy
it because it is
burn through it as fast as you can so
you can get to the raid and then you're
like what happened to the story i have
no idea because i wasn't paying
attention i hit skip as fast as i can
like and that's not fun to go through
that and be like what happened
i think i know but i'll probably go play
it on my second character when i
actually pay attention to the story
as opposed to burning through strikes
over and over and stuff like that now
you might be able to enjoy it more
switch between a couple if you're going
for leveling
the contest was one of the better things
that i think they put in
and i'll be kind of curious how the
artifact power being disabled plays out
since that's not going to give you any
benefit i wonder how hard it's actually
going to be able to get up there because
that's one
for the no lifers that's the one that
would be your advantage
i say no lifers but i mean in 11 days at
some point you are going to sleep in
there
but as like artifact power it's like now
it is truly
you probably not he's got to make notes
and write and everything else
but like now you truly are on like
powerfuls and pinnacles and stuff of
that it's honestly weird to me they
disabled it
completely if they gave you a cap that
you could earn like hey
here's this we have an idea how many
powerfuls you'll probably get in 11 days
you play a decent amount we'll give you
10 on artifact anything but the fact
that it's not there to help like
bad rng on some people's roles i guess
and maybe in 11 days
it's going to be fine if the if it's you
know the powerful
cap is 1200 and the pinnacle all that
stuff if it's similar
i'm still just kind of curious how
everything kind of plays out but believe
me the date
i'm good it's 11 days if it was 18 and
thanksgiving
wasn't there i could see it probably
going either way and then for contest
mode
that's the one that just kind of it
levels the playing field so no matter
how much you get to play in those 11
days
if you can get in there and you've got
enough power somebody might have more
expertise and more aspects and fragments
on their stasis subclasses and stuff
like that
but they're still able to jump in so i'm
good with this one
um two to three weeks sounds pretty good
at this point just no longer that three
to four because i'm with you
we want somewhat of a decent schedule
yeah three to four days i mean
definitely is that that was rough you
know what i'm saying i think um
you know also we got to take into
account that this season was delayed
also
right so we have to see the cadence of
when arrivals you know when i mean not
right but
beyond like this um what you call when
it ends right is it
you know one would assume they're gonna
keep the normal cadence
which means you know another condensing
of this season
and if that's the case another reason as
to why we can't really push it out too
far
the raid anyway so also the other thing
we're not thinking about is this you
know
i know of a big fear about pushing it
out is you know
oh we're rushing through but if you
remember with you know forsaken and
stuff
the raid and stuff was also contingent
with the dreaming city so who knows
if they have some story beat in
conjunction with it right
and there's a lot of things that
sometimes get revealed later we didn't
even
know about the dreaming city before we
just thought it was the barons
and we were in tango shore avenge cave
unfortunately it was a 10-day release
that was the nice thing about it
right because it wasn't a three-day and
i missed that so that's why i have faith
in this you know what i'm saying i'm not
i'm not gonna gonna freak out you know
say because my thing is like yo
dale shout out to kakis he's got a good
video right now
and um it's been actually been out for a
while just in reference to
how bungie does their price structure
every expansion right and i believe like
rise and i was like maybe thirty dollars
or whatever whatever
and a little less whatever and maybe
shadow kid i think fell in that thing
but forsaken was that premium price if
y'all remember
right beyond light is hitting that price
and bungie in my opinion does a fair
estimation of value so i think there's a
lot of stuff we still don't know i know
me and ue are definitely concerned like
all they're showing the stasis powers
and even me travis we talked about it
like we hope that's just not it and
there's more meat right yeah
but i think again i shouted i think it
was the way you described it i think the
deep stone crep
i just naturally assumed was the
specific raid
area and that's it we'll just go there
boom yeah and he's alluding that that
might be a
whole i don't see like a dream in city
that might be an area and the raider
also is in
part of that but that could be its own
area in itself so i'm waiting to see how
things play out
and i think value sometimes equates to
content with bungie
so i'm curious to see you know we may
have some secrets here we may
so there's no need to hold on and
necessarily drag this thing out
because we may have stuff cooking so
that's what yeah i think you might be
right because
it i could be wrong about this i haven't
i haven't kept up on the grimoire
in you know like a year but uh if i'm
not mistaken the
deep stone crypt is not on europa it's
supposed to be on some other
cells this is like yeah yeah yeah i i
i'm pretty sure i mean if you're doing
the raid they're either going to have
some
way for you to get there or they're just
going to retcon it and change its
location
because because everything in the
grimoire is a rumor it could not be true
that's what they said i mean
everything's like it's like legends
right so it doesn't have to be
uh canon it's canon until they say it
isn't um
yeah we're like george lucas exactly
borrow from greatness mcclunkey
uh full circle
yeah i could absolutely see the deep
stone crypt being attached to its own
traversable area
that to me would be best case scenario
more likely
uh situation is that earth is somehow
the second
location and that we get because we're
going back to
um going back to the cosmodrome and i
could see that
having a lot of story implications in
the campaign
and also the content that follows the
campaign so
you know there might be some some times
there or something
we'll see we'll see where they actually
go with it but uh i would be
very shocked because my impression i
think we talked about this
uh when you're on fire team chat cog
which is that like
my impression is that this one is going
to be a little bit light and that
they're kind of prepping us for this is
like the rise of iron right and they're
prepping us for
uh the witch queen and i think that's
going to be the one that really changes
things so
i really hope that i'm wrong um
but we'll see we'll see very excited
though yeah i was like i'm kind of
i'm with your boat it's like i know
they've said cosmodrome is like the
second destination they're gonna flesh
it
out for year four if i can get all these
numbers right
uh and that's i think what they remember
they were saying like we're gonna have
the new light kind of
experience on the cosmodrome and then as
the seasons progress they said they'd be
flushing out cosmodrome
i've also heard rumors or somebody said
it officially and i can never remember
like stasis on europa is eventually
going to be coming
to other enemy races over the course of
like year four as well potentially uh
seeing it in different places
so the fact that the overall like entire
director could see more stasis and
changes in cosmodrome could get
that may be the way they drag it out but
i was like i'm i'm with you guys if i
could
get the giant surprise of deep zone
crypt enceladus is that like baby extra
destination
something else is like that one major
secret that we don't know
that's what i was about to say because i
was trying to take dogs
like europa's been developed for what
six years now it's been like
year one so i mean not saying like it
was done then and they're like oh we
finally put it in the game no they like
they hammered this thing home for sure
now but they had a framework to work
with and they've been building on it for
a long time so they finally like
polished it it's like
well cosmodrome that got some polish
europa
was kinda built did they have time for
something else and that's like that's
one of those were like
i don't want to get expectations too
high but man that would be one of those
surprises you're like
that's the chef's kiss for me like
that's the surprise on that one if you
can
if they can sneak something like that in
raise them razor because
i agree with you because listen they've
been sitting on these assets we've heard
about europa for
so long you know what i said so i i
firmly agree and the thing is this too i
got i got to give ian loof
i gotta tweak him a little bit right
bother right now you are that's normal
king you are the king of complaining
they tell us too much in the trailers
they gave they killed i mean
i totally will claim
you and you're like now i'm worried
because i don't know if there's going to
be enough context
i will fully claim that i will be like
hey i don't want to i don't want them to
hand me an exotic i don't want them to
show me all the exotics in a trailer
before we actually get the guns now
they're fighting data miners that's a
different issue but
true i will claim that 100 but on the
other side like
it's also the surprises are good and
but again like again just kind of the
feeling of like
covet being a thing like they've
mentioned like armor's not really
changing yeah we're getting subclasses
which forcato was like
we get new subclasses we get fragments
we get aspects we get stasis weapons
potentially
shields on enemies so that's like a
shift in the game
but as for destinations like those are
just surprises but again i'm kind of
with travis where i was like
i still have this weird feeling and like
gnawing in the back of my head that this
is going to be
smaller than i would like and i can't
quite put a pin on why
but again you know why because i i've
thought about this this is why
it's because in the past any time a big
dlc is coming out
we all felt it and bungie was not afraid
to
just promote the hell out of it forsaken
night and day to what we're getting now
they promoted that so much there is an
important caveat here though
which is that we haven't really gotten a
taste of bungie promoting itself without
activision because activision was its
publisher
and activision had the money for all the
marketing and stuff so it could be that
this is
uh this there's no precedent for this
but we haven't really seen
how bungie behaves when they're
marketing their own thing and it's huge
how much are they willing to hide now
that they're fully in control because i
think
in the past activision was like no no no
you're showing that like
we're seeing as much of this as possible
because we need to get people to buy
this game so
i think that there's a there's a chance
that you and i
we're like being pessimistic because we
are used to that
this is this is new i really hope that's
the case because if there's any reason
to buy back your own
ip to use it it's to do something like
this to like
delight your loyal fan base with
something that they will never see
coming
and i think that they have a really good
opportunity to do that i hope that's the
case i got faith in luke man
i got faith man that guy's great that's
my guess
he's one of my boys yes but dude i've
had a chance to beat them
but um oh you haven't oh i've never met
luke so salute to you like that's that's
my guy all right
like this is great oh it's awesome and
uh what what when what you said
resonated because
i remember during the forsaken
days and the activision earnings call
slander yeah and i remember luke got up
and said
oh no we we are happy we are impressed
we are not ashamed of what we did
accomplish with forsaken
because at that time the rhetoric was
financially it disappointed it didn't
live to expectation
according to you know the big activism
and he was like yo
not over here we're proud of what we did
and i'm like oh no luke don't get fired
at that time i didn't know i didn't know
they were leaving right now i didn't
know they had plans
i was like oh no luke went against the
suits it's over
you know what i'm saying but like salute
to him and they believe
so much in the product and um look man
listen he he
he knows his game you know him and i
don't want to make it just shout out to
noseworthy right those two work
in conjunction mark knows it together a
lot and um
i i think we're going to be in for a
surprise man big expansion
they never disappoint for the most part
man you you you can even if you didn't
like shadow
you can't say he wasn't terrible you
know saying like i would say that
yeah the fall expansion we always get
something so
stay tuned man buckle up have a little
faith man
the king is coming back man coming back
yeah
i agree with that assessment on
shadowkeep i i refuted it for ign gave
it a 7.8 which in
ign lingo back in the old grading system
uh was good not great
yeah almost great almost not great
though like it didn't really get there
so
and i i still stand by that like all
this time later because it
feels about right that's fair yeah i i
had some i almost created that should be
on the box almost great
yeah going back to luke is like i
remember back in the
i'm lucky enough i've gotten to talk and
and interview a lot of the people bungie
over the years just being
hanging out at their office and like the
the thing about luke is he
back even before he was in a leadership
position he said
his stated goal as as somebody who
worked at bungie and had some influence
was to make
destiny as much like an rpg as possible
because a lot of people forget
that when definitely vanilla came out
come on yeah
when destiny when vanilla came out it
was not like an rpg at all
its menus were super limited uh it did
not have a whole lot of
upgrade systems and stuff and he sort of
nerdfied it that
his brainchild with the taken king the
thing that was like
he the thing that he drove home was the
quest tab
that got added during the taking that
was the amazing ending
amazing changed everything it completely
changed the way that players interacted
with
the game and i think um you know when
destiny 2 vanilla came out
i remember it was way less nerdy it was
less rpgs
they kind of sort of pulled it back yeah
i remember i talked to
i talked to luke smith we were at this
like the only time just got done my
faith was shaking continue
yeah yeah that's my only time
yeah so i had played it before it came
out and and i remember i was talking to
luke at like a bar event
you know that night and i was like hey
do you remember you told me that
you want your goals to make it more rpg
what happened
and this is before the game came out i
was like like what like what why is it
like why did you take away the quest tab
the quest tab was not in
destiny 2 when it launched which i
thought was crazy because i was like
luke's in like a position of power now
how is the quest tab gone that was like
his thing
and he told me it was just too confusing
man it was just like a lot of stuff
you know that was basically his answer i
don't i didn't i wasn't recording him i
didn't write it down
i just remember that was like his
sentiment was like it was just
overwhelming it was a little bit much
and we're trying to like
streamline it make it simpler and then
he talked about that
side tab that you hold the left trigger
and it comes out right
on the menu he talked about that and i
was just like that's not the same thing
and you know it like yeah
yeah no rpg mechanics that's not the
system
he came from the world of warcraft like
that's where his that's right
a lot of his world came from so for me
and cognito probably
will never be happier if i ever shut up
about that game
uh but i mean i played that thing for
hours and hours and hours i had two
characters with like
you know over a month on each so i was
like i spent plenty and it's like
diablos and all those like i grew
up through all of that in the same thing
so tell me more about world of warcraft
let me eat
what my my druid and uh what uh lit what
is the wrath of the lich king and all
that stuff
that's me if if you're a character in
mass effect i'm trying to romance that's
my dialogue option
tell me more about the justice cards i'd
he wanted to make it more rpg like in me
i'm sitting over here coming from
whether it be chrono trigger or world of
warcraft or true rpgs and
like for me part of me is like i'm kind
of still waiting
and i know that sounds kind of harsh but
i was like if you say mmorpg and i play
destiny i'm like you're not
there yet in my opinion because there's
a long ways to go between stats
skill trees all of those things that
kind of go into it's still very much a
shooter like armor
especially right now yeah we're getting
a fifth mod socket
which is a great thing i'm not gonna be
mad about that but again armor overall
there's not a lot of like tie to the
stats and everything mobility doesn't
actually make you
run faster which just still blows my
mind to this day there are certain
things
when it comes to that it's very weird
yeah like it literally even the text
says makes you move faster i'm like no
it doesn't makes you walk faster and
straight faster it does not make you
sprint faster which is still movement so
um so you have like you have ability
recharges which are a separate thing
anyway
but it's like i mean me i'm always
always pictured like
a titan being tanky like coming from an
rpg build and a warrior being able to be
up there and actually take the damage
and the bubble kind of gives a little
bit of that but that's not really
i can't take twice as much damage as the
warlock who's crushing damage
that's one of so i was like am i really
doing this what yeah
you just got an exotic that gives you an
overshadow we really doing this
continue i don't have this entire thing
i've tolerated vote for y'all
for a while now now we really doing this
time i cannot
wait for my overshield to get back
that's gonna be nice
hey but you know what yeah i was talking
about this on fire team chat because
they were complaining about this too
because they're
dirty hunters and warlocks
which is they were like oh yeah titans
are gonna get overshield this isn't fair
i'm like bro
they're giving everybody grenades that
create walls our
class ability is now useless it's just a
duplicate like you can see through it
but like it's the
so of course they have to give us a way
to like trade our
class ability in for something that
other people don't have right they're
giving giving hunters the
ability to teleport to the blink now
it's just like
to me i mean there's a lot of mixing
going on but i i'm sort of
i'd challenge you e because i'm i kind
of think i don't want it to be world of
warcraft
i'm one of the guys who's i'm kind of
like cog where world of warcraft is a
little too much for me i'm afraid of it
becoming like that i don't want it to be
like
like a really complicated do you want to
place anyone like skill trees for
example though would you like something
closer
i would like something closer to that i
think the gold standard for the shooter
shoot looter shooters is something like
borderlands 3
or division right like the division two
has a really good way of where you can
build your own classes that are
equipment based and you can kind of be
like
i'm gonna spec into this type of this
this class but
i don't want it to be full wow where
there's just like
a million things to think about and a
500 different currencies and i'm
spending 50 000 coins to buy you know
yeah all that stuff i'm sure robot
agrees he said too many currencies it
would be hell
yeah there's already too many currencies
there's already too many and we're about
to get started
i've talked about this before but i
think it's hilarious that there is now a
joke currency that is a real currency
inside destiny you can get it right now
a chocolate strange coin which is a fake
edible version of an
old currency from d1 that nobody liked
them existed and now it's dead
they're just trolling they're just
trying to see based on it other
currency like that they're really
they're they've really gone places in
this game so i was like
i kind of i hope that destiny becomes
the perfect middle ground between
world of warcraft and a traditional
shooter that doesn't really give you any
power over how you play
i think that's always been like the the
goal for destiny and i think that
they've gotten close
and never gotten their bully and i'm
excited to see if they can do it but i
do think they tend to get
closer at least since destiny 2 vanilla
came out
they've gotten closer with each
expansion and given us more freedom and
more power
and this what they're doing with classes
with the
the um darkness ability the fact that
you're getting mods for your classes
it is going there so they can do
something like that
uh and make it moddable but not so much
that i'm
you know killing uh chickens to get bone
parts for my armor type that i want to
transfuse like as long as i don't have
to get there
i'll be happy i can get on board with
that that i can agree because
yeah it's like world is like there are
literally 50 hotkeys i joke but yeah i
was like that's too much
but on the other side it's like when
they say mmor rpg it was like
there's a few more pieces maybe not all
the way but it's like and as you said
the customizing of stasis
this is like their little baby
brainchild i'm honestly curious as this
is the first one
solar arc and void how are they going to
consolidate switch up because we have
three different supers in each of those
are they going to strip some of them out
keep the favorite one is bubble gonna be
the sentinel subclass
period what about the shield that they
like developed and put the time into
is that going to be an ad uh aspect or
fragment that
actually makes those so i'm like i am so
curious to see what this does
into other stuff i still wish stats had
a little more weight to them for
values of things but that's still me but
i was like i'm with you like the stasis
stuff that i saw and we talked about
that when that came up i was just like
this is for one a really cool thing and
i'm also very curious how to handle the
rest of them
because we have three supers
and then they have one so i'm kind of
curious where that all coincides
yeah no i think i think you guys nailed
it i think um you know with with luke
and these guys
you know the fact that we finally got
them to actually say
you know uh it's it's it's an mmo right
like like
they used to run from that you know when
you whenever you get a sound by
oh we're not this we're not that so
again i think
to travis's point it goes to them maybe
now separating themselves from
activision
truly pushing the boundary on their
vision and i just think it's going to be
incremental to
ultimately what they want to get to i
don't know if it's going to be what is
it uh
why'd i always butcher the name it's
scarlet queen taking
what's the name of the damn dlc with
saboteur uh
the witchcraft which questions which
queen i don't know why i butchered that
i could never say
witch queen you know i say is is that
the ultimate thing you know
life fall i think there is a trajectory
i think there is an ending to where they
they want to go
and whether it be system-wise
incrementally how they're going to do it
and stacey's maybe one of the setting
points
we're getting a content vault we're
getting a
pseudo engine update in the same breath
with stuff coming in with the cosmodrome
this new version of it you know what i'm
saying kind of thing
so i think it's incremental they're
doing as much as they can i think
as an independent and it's funny like so
big studio what i'm calling them india
it's bizarre bizarre
such a unique story of a budget but um
yeah man i think we'll get there but i
will
fight for e on armor well e
i will go to war with him that armor
still
needs that i mean they're the masters of
weapons they're the
masters of the intricacies of that stuff
and
but i really want them to dive a little
bit more you know what i'm saying
with armor upgrades and like you said
even if it's barring
division with the gear sets and specking
out
man oh like they really and then you
know exotic armor you know how i feel
about
the constant revisiting of the standbys
that they did say because of the new
system
hopefully the sandbox revisit cadence is
going to get updated quicker
right because i hate that we got only
time we get an update is when the new
expansion comes up right
like we should have a cadence either in
like a halfway point as well
where there's another update and we
don't have to wait as long you know i
mean because
these things really excite me it really
gets you to go about wow they changed
this wow they reworked this exotic
cool like i want to get in there i want
to see how this affects the sandbox kind
of thing
so i think we're gonna get there it's
just incremental remember they still
on their own you know without that that
backing so just that's just my opinion
on it
but we'll see yeah somehow this all came
from a raid discussion but we
fell off of that topic a little while
ago
in fairness to this uh professional that
we've got joining us there's one more
piece that i do want to touch
and it is the fact that we've got the
investigation and delayed announcement
for the finish of the world's first
the fact that it's not gonna be like hey
we finished they did it cool they're
gonna like do some data analysis
check if like you fired six thousand
times in one second that doesn't seem to
be right
like yep i mean this is straight up just
because of cheating and mostly would you
guys imagine
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah i mean because
pc players are the worst
oh evil i didn't go down
absolutely the the
there there's not there's nothing i to
me it's like a sacred ritual for
for destiny players right like the
world's first has been
so cool and everybody gets so excited
and watches all these streams and it
would be really
irritating if while these streams are
going on you figured out that there's
some group of like hackers that just
like
gave themselves infinite health and and
got through it in 20 minutes or whatever
i don't think that that's gonna happen
because to be honest
who what serious rape team is dying
because they're losing health right
they're dying because they're not
meeting the mechanical part of it
and they they can't figure out the
puzzle and they all wipe at the same
time so
in all likelihood that's not going to be
the case but i do think it's good that
they're thinking about this before we
get a situation where they announce the
world first and then they
investigate and find out that it
actually wasn't real i think it's
happening at
exactly the right time but yeah they're
they're doing it for the cheating thing
and
i hope that there's um i hope they they
do
what they did with um the dreaming city
uh
raid uh because of riven the last wish
because uh i really liked that there was
like a ceremony for it right like when
they
beat the raid everybody logged back on
to go see
the uh you know the the video play and
there was it
it changed the world and started off the
the the three week cycle
i thought that was so so so cool and i
would love to see them
uh do something or take this opportunity
since they're giving some distance to
the raid uh create some sort of
ceremonial way to kind of like honor
these or change the world
uh when it happens but yeah i i think
it's it's for
cheaters but i hope they use it for
something that is that is cool
now that they have some kind of distance
from it and that's why
you literally gave the reason for why
um last wish is so sacred to me i vote
the guy is always number one but
i never argue with anyone who puts last
wish
as one or two or whatever because that
raid the way it
ended and just even the sequence of the
queen's walk with the heart like that
extra you
don't remember no i thought the raid was
oh don't get me started you know how i
feel about that music
it's amazing so it's like it's part it's
a part of it used in gambit as well but
um
you know just walking out with the heart
and then that extra segment and then you
see
i forgot the clan's name that one was it
resonable i forgot the name
but anyway um that was such a redeem
yeah it was such a cool
thing to see how emotional they were
like
it really resonated like the world's
first is something amazing so with this
anti-cheat thing you know i'm liking
that they're gonna take their time
they're gonna
wait you know what i'm saying and the
other sad thing that we did learn women
when all the dirtiness came out about
the destiny community and what was going
on
they some other stuff that was found out
was other teams
were getting dosed and hacked during
their world's first attempt
that's bernie and that broke my heart
when i found out that i never knew that
i think it was
one goth team was a failure yeah
catholic they were getting ddos
da i had no idea so to think about
what could have been for that team if
they were not impeded
if they were not manipulated you know
against and um
i love this approach because we need a
fair
winner you know what i'm saying and not
saying no one's not going to fail but
i'm just saying like we need it vetted
right
all the way through and then you know i
have no problem with this but yeah man
this is cool this is i love that they're
taking this approach and um yeah man i'm
excited i'm excited to see how this
thing plays out and it would be cool if
they
they do some type of transitionary you
know saying peace like you said trying
to be dope
yeah i think that'd be the cool thing
for them to get back to
is to have because that's as you said
like taking king is still one of my
favorites for sure
is because of oryx regicide the lore the
the whole connection from crota all the
way through to your floating
spit like hive god off into space who's
by scale
massive so it's like when you get all of
that connected then the last wish again
these massive bosses now that's the
weird thing for me is like
what are we gonna fight because that's
what my worry is like i'm with you guys
when you talked about zal earlier
i'm worried aramis is going to be zoll
yeah aramis like the darkness queen
stuff or
kel um and she's got that she's the one
we're going to face in this like
campaign on the top of a tower
and then i have no idea how it's gonna
connect but it's like it's always as
you've said
cognito for lauren you even said it so
when you've talked to anybody at bungie
it's like
when the lore of the story ties into the
raid and it connects to the world
that's when some of this stuff is the
best and that's as you said travis
if they can use this delay it's a little
farther out then it kickstarts something
else in the world
that's where i think it could really
come together yeah it's destiny at its
best yeah
you're right the taking now that i think
about it i guess i've never thought of
it that way but
the only raid that really directly i
think everybody knew how it tied into
the campaign was the taken king because
vault of glass is sort of like an
afterthought like the vex turn out to be
kind of the final boss of the game but
vault of glass is sort of just like a
separate thing
uh wrath of the machines really i still
don't really even know what that was
about
me because rather machine that boss
deserved better
i wasn't sure it says axis deserved he
was an amazing
encounter and he deserved a better lore
for how amazing that thing was but
continue yeah it would have been great
if he was somehow the face of
the evil in that campaign but the
campaign didn't have a face of evil
because it was about three missions long
and about 25 minutes worth of content
uh but yeah i hate that campaign sorry
it's not very good uh but yeah the and i
i think that that's that's the problem
here right is is
i think you're right we're pro we're
going to be fighting because we know
it's in a separate location the raid
right so it's probably going to be
completely disconnected and it was the
same thing with gaul why couldn't golf
have been
at the very least lasted until the raid
but instead he died and then
who the heck is this callous guy like
why isn't he showing the adventure he
talks about callus
yeah yeah an adventure talks about him
if you haven't read the grimoire you
have no idea what's going on i'm sure
most people who've played the raids
still don't know like how kalis fits
into the picture
i have no idea you know facts effects
yeah i felt val valkyr [ __ ] was was
mishandled it's
inspired stars and and you know he knows
the jokes i have for the raid layers you
know
clean apartments
and go finish you know go empty his
garage and eat
something like that we're just doing
errands for this man like it was
really no lore that con we had curse of
osiris which
obviously osiris i'm a huge fan boy
crazy warlock lore that i want to know
about
that story ends you know pudding out
these fight was cool
but then it's like it had no narrative
connection
like to eater of worlds like it's just
like oh carlos is
something like and e like you said when
we were at um you know
gcx you know i definitely went
to the raid team group and i was like
look guys you know
when you are at your best last wish
taken king when you have that narrative
build up
even i will give leviathan this i'll
finish
i like that when you flew in right and
you got a little whatever and the same
thing when you flew in the last wish
and petra is talking and telling you why
you're doing this why
i think all this is important to build
it up narratively
then when you end it you also have to
make like you said travis
this villain has to be a threat you just
can't just throw a random villain with a
name
and then we're supposed to have some
emotional attachment to why we're kill
him
it doesn't it's not it's not earned you
know what i'm saying that that's my
fault that's my problem with it
so i just want them to continue with
that cadence because i again i do fear
for what's the aramis that you know it's
gonna be forgotten yeah she's gonna be
you know
it what it is missions against fallen
baby going back to the cosmodrome for
one or two
finish up on europa fight her at the top
of a tower
then other stuff happens i'm like they
don't connect and that's that's where as
like
again these separate stories somebody
said like panoptis for cursive
for carlos mm-hmm
the look of that guy and i have a whole
that intro mission where they show all
the different realities
yes you see he's like his plan like this
is what he he's trying to do i thought
that was really cool
the entire rest of the campaign is is
really bad but like that whole premise
could have been really good if they
would
absolutely double down on it and one of
the one of the few bosses where actually
the npc
soros fought with you for a little bit
you know like right i want to see more
of that like
they've got so much even the last wish
good raid but like
most people aren't going to know who
riven is you know it wasn't like we were
fighting aldrin solve in that rage
like i i still think that they could
have done a better job of the narrative
threads there and it's
it's kind of the story of destiny
limitless storytelling potential
that more often than not goes unused
right
well i think that's a pretty damn good
place to end it yeah outside of the i
was like we got emblems to earn for
first you know 24 hours and all that
stuff the emblems do you guys
fancy either the purple or the red one
either of those
i know you want the day one you're gonna
have to get it it's for your job you're
required sir you're getting paid for it
yeah but other than that you'll be able
to get your raid jacket
and be curious what that one looks like
yes do you have any raid jackets or is
it just suits only
it doesn't count no i think i've
unlocked them but i've never paid for
them
because you still have to pay like 60
bucks right so i just like they were
like it was like 140
they were not cheap oh
that would be something i would frame
and put on the wall behind me you know
i'm not actually going to wear it so
well hey if you do this one and get that
you might have to do this one just to
just to you know add it to the wall
to flex yeah make sense i was never i
was never expecting on this being a
recording studio you know
yeah you got to put the stranger statue
back there now you got the drifter
statue i saw just came out like
you got stuff to add back there we got
to say
uh before you know we do have to say
goodbye to a favorite guardian seriously
this is oh that's right
yeah cannot end this show no that's what
i was saying goodbye
to one of the greatest community
managers
of all time i've been around a lot and
um
deeds man it hit me when you when you
sent me that taxi i was i couldn't
believe because i was just worried about
the law stuff he's like you didn't get
to the end i'm like oh
i gotta get ketchup i didn't know and
man
yeah this i want to let you guys go you
know i'm saying like how are you
processing the legendary deeds moving on
i was like i'll give the guest honors
because
you know you're the guest man yeah well
deeja is a friend of mine
um you know i've spent a lot of time
with him he's a really good guy he's
charismatic he's
uh funny uh he is friendly to anyone and
will
find ways to like build connections with
you and he he built a hell of a team
um obviously that's that's that's kind
of sad in its own right anybody moving
on
but uh you know more than that i think
the way that this affects the destiny
community is
i think destiny and bungie in general
but especially destiny since that's what
they've been doing these past
six years they're the gold standard for
community management i i really think
that they they have one of the hardest
games to manage which is
a huge game from a major studio that's
got lots of expectations
they play they make a game that lots of
people really love and have tons of
opinions about
and more often than not they've been
really communicative really responsive
uh and they always feel like they're
being respectful to their community and
uh on twit they're they're on reddit you
know in the destiny the game reddit
like commenting uh they even hired
somebody from the destiny of the game
reddit that's where cosmo came from you
know
uh so they they really um have
have kind of i think set the bar and so
obviously when you look at the guy who
built that
um leaving it's sad but i mean he could
not be leaving it in better hands
that much is clear and uh i i don't know
if i'll ever see him again
because he's he's moving on and i you
know it's a pandemic i'm not going
anywhere right now but i
i won't be able to uh see him in person
more often than not but
deej if you ever see this you're awesome
and
uh always had great memories with you
thanks for welcoming me and lots of
other people
into bungie hq and even more people uh
you know the streams that you did and
and all that so we will miss you we will
not miss you talking about service
regime alone
no one is going to miss that the gun is
not good
absolutely
you you got some words before i get into
my deeds
yeah uh it was hard to follow travis and
i know you're gonna go but it was like
for watching what he always did whether
it be
his talent in e3s
and answering not answering questions
uh his dramatic readings on the twitch
streams
when you meet him in person for the
first time if he had the time
he would share a beer with every single
person whether he drinks or not but it
was like he would do that with every
single person if time allowed
like he is in like i mean got a chance
we got like three seconds with him at
guardian con
alternate i mean could not be like a
nicer guy
and to see like as you said plucked
cosmo from reddit
dylan up there now he's got nicole so
he's taken this time to build a team
set the standard and i mean i don't know
how
bungie did a few special things with
destiny from the start
one was you know they combined options
of like a shooter
an mmo tried to make it this weird mesh
that shouldn't have worked and somehow
vault of glass was the cherry on top
that gave it the extra spring of life
that it needed
but the other thing is they made a
community that has been
more supportive uh more helpful
the the things that have come out of
this community for the fact that it
like i don't know of another game that
has a community like this it does not
exist
and he is one of the people who made
that happen
like the way he talked about it the way
he would be out there his twabs that you
would read
all of the pieces that he did were
integral in making this game have the
community that it does
and without him it's one of those pieces
like it may not even be the same
experience
he like not saying there's like 800
people in the studio that didn't make
the game but he is one of those like
rare gems that set this community and
the experience we got throughout it
apart
so i was like again deej if you ever see
this as well
i got to meet you for about five seconds
but i will say thank you from so much of
the community for doing
what you did in a way that possibly only
you could have done
yeah the the end well
yeah i mean yeah the other thing i
hadn't even thought about this i don't
know if you guys know this but
but deej himself also came from uh the
community like he was on the bungie
forums and that's where they found him
so it's kind of funny that he kind of
then hired out of the community and
that's there's a nice symmetry to it but
yeah he's he's good and
and we'll miss him yeah i mean well you
guys
said him so much man he looks man he
for me as you know what my history is is
such became a person who
started to was a hater of the game when
i didn't know about the end game
to the staunch defender that how dare
you slander you know saying
and it's like the hardest thing the
better sweep for me
is when a new stream is going to come
out and he's not going to be there
because to to look forward to the new
x-man
he's such a showman and he's such a
presenter and he does a good job of not
only
serving the base he does a good job
protecting
the bungee employees you know and and
like he's saying
he's so slick with the words you he'll
give you enough but not just enough to
to protect the team and like he's so
good with that like he is a tactician
he's a wordsmith
with that type of professionalism but pr
like the man is uh
amazing so salute to him um and i
remember like i said i met him a few
times
and each time was pleasant and you know
i always told him i i
told him i said look man i said off
right i said you can tell us
us that's fans we we we awful sometimes
you got like
we are the most demanding
base all you got to do is this what
bunga
this like we're bad sometimes like i'm
guilty of it we get emotional we love
the game and when things don't
work and he said no bro i love it
because he said
we are we have to serve the community we
need that feedback you know what i'm
saying and um
he's just excellent man he's just
professional i wish him the best at you
know whatever his next journey
may take him whoever's getting them
don't get a winner whoever it is
whatever wherever he's going you're
getting a winner like this this guy
and again he he for me he was the face
of destiny during those dark times
when i would tune in to these streams
and you read those 12 he knows like when
we started
you know flashpoint slash last word like
we would
tune in to these swabs feverishly just
for hope
okay they're doing this they're building
that and you look for that deej out
you're like you don't say like
that brought you joy with the game
wasn't doing good because you know they
were working you know they were
listening and
yeah man it it it's it's it's cool to
see
everyone in the community kind of rally
up and celebrate them so i thought that
was dope
and we wish him the best so again dj if
you're hearing it it's my favorite one
of my favorite world like oh he wrapped
that world like class
so well he made it his business to put
that warlock
out yes he could oh hello actually you
guys talking about him is reminding me
of so many good memories i have with him
i remember you know the sparrow racing
league when they were showing that off
at e3
uh he just let me stay in the room and
like
spare sparrow race with him for a really
long time i think he was happy it was
the one competitive mode he could beat
me at
and uh yeah so and then i remember
my i think my best memory with him is we
were walking around the
bungee office and he was giving some
other people who'd never been there
before
a tour and i was just kind of like
hanging out i remember for part of the
tour he walked by this room that was
supposed to be closed
and behind the door you could just see
these big monitors and they said destiny
2 on it and this was before destiny 2
had even been announced
and he just looked at the people all of
us journalists we'd all seen it
and then he looked he looked at the
monitor and then he looked at us all
like this
and then he just goes you knew it was
coming and he just
carried on he just kept walking
he was a master showman and the last
thing i well funny little memories i
remember like
you know just he would do fun things
during the stream too like
it was just like the way you present
like i remember he made like
fashion a thing he was like okay now
here's the warlock and the the hunter
with their ensemble wearing the the
future world cult gear you just do funny
things to present the game
in such a cool way that you had to laugh
we all know about the memes we know
about the smoking jacket
he's a showman man like i said whoever
gets him one of the
best community managers i've ever seen
and
and salute to him a lot of fun members
he will definitely be
missed well that i think is where we
have to wrap the show up
and the proper place to do it too man
uh travis it has been an absolute blast
having you i'm sorry
we kept you so long um it has and been
an absolute pleasure
the floor is yours um if you got
anything cool cooking obviously we know
you got the review but
stuff you got working if you got
anything planned any cool projects
i mean floor is yours anybody who
listens tears or otherwise
tell them about you tell them to go
watch star wars one more time whatever
you got
yeah go ahead please watch the mcclunky
scene from star wars and think of me
uh and not of anything else no but
i'm gonna be on the destiny show next
week i'm on fire tv show every week
uh on which we record and release on
fridays at 5 p.m
um and then you can check out my review
of gentian impact on ign.com and then
on november 22nd hopefully
uh you will see my review for destiny 2.
beyond light nice nice
that's plenty to do between now and then
absolutely
such a pleasure to have you here man
have talked to you for hours but you're
fantastic
good job same here i feel like we get
along i i get i get to hang out with you
guys for
the rest of the evening there's somebody
behind
a camera or a door over there who
probably wants you back
absolutely she's actually sitting right
over here and she's waiting to play
destiny
with me thank you that's amazing
that's the keyboard thank her for us by
the way
yes i will salute them again if you're
not following
chad please follow him you know sit on
twitter and again fire team chat
always does a fantastic job welcome to
being with obama made me feel at home
my first time in the stage so salute to
you man i had a lot of fun and invested
in the whole team man i love what you
guys do
and definitely looking forward to that
but up yeah for me you already know at
lord cognito on twitter
iron lords podcast every sunday is the
lord's day this week we will have the
wondering
dutch so up and coming content creator
uh oh you gotta do sit ups uh-oh
did they wait someone put in the chat it
was a long time ago but it's there oh
he's gotta do oh this is the best part
of the show right now so right now
who was the one that probably missed
that so oh he's got to do sit-ups y'all
yes so it's happening all right so we
here at the last word during the
pandemic we really promote fitness
as you can see ee bonches is a fitness
connoisseur and he serves his community
well
so the chat asked for it they demand it
and we're getting this perfect form
himself look at that
the knee the elbows meeting the knees
the perfect form
he's like what's happening this is
fitness at the last word y'all
and this is what we do here we're
getting in shape we're pandemic out
we're
stage four five of the panda we're
almost at the gym but we got to keep
this we got to promote this here
at the last where he is a is the
champion the spokesperson
for fitness and thanks to the chat who
put it in the chat i missed it
i missed it who put in the
that was redeemed at like the top of the
show so i gotta give it to you right
you're welcome salute now no more now
come on now it's the end of the show
the new red light can we get a second
episode you get a dab relax
my man just you know just put in some
hard work right now so that's what you
get here this is
we're gonna keep it we're gonna keep it
tight
everybody get out there fit this is
important man during the code don't let
the kova belly get you man he's out here
he's moving he's moving and grooving for
you right now so that's that's what we
got see
you he's because he's like what is
happening
i have no idea what's happening and also
very support this worthy cause
yes we gotta give my man that sponsor
right now man he's killing it out here
his boy
both fitness love it love it my salute
to him as i was saying
hello podcast on sundays at 11 00 a.m
eastern
and we'll have one drink dutch on one of
the awesome guys in the community from
the mixed up podcast
we'll be talking about next-gen stuff
we'll be talking about the playstation 5
ui
we'll be talking about field specials
comments on the bethesda acquisition
a lot of stuff going on 900p games on
the series us we got to talk about it
so there's going to be a lot of stuff
there please check us out and again i
can't thank enough everyone for the
support lords of gaming.net man
really been flourishing thanks to you
guys sharing the articles
you know it's been so cool to see so
support our guys there
and um yeah man you know that last word
you know how we do man one of the best
podcasts you've ever heard yet you heard
it
most people didn't beforehand thanks to
chapman
so salute to anybody new that's coming
in to support the chat's been amazing
really appreciate the growth and we'd
love to see you know what i'm saying
the support so thank you guys very much
and e
what's going on with you sir i'm just
kidding
[Laughter]
no um honestly travis it has been an
absolute
pleasure to have you on as i think i
probably am in the same places he's like
we could probably talk for another
couple hours whether we
brought up crazy i didn't even get to
like mess with you about your fast and
furious knowledge i got a place
i was like i know i saw that but i was
like we moved so far beyond that topic i
couldn't even get there i was like i've
seen them all too but it sounds like you
would be a hilarious person to talk
about that stuff with but
nah man you are absolutely welcome on
here anytime if you're like i got a
little freedom on a friday
you are absolutely welcome so it has
been a pleasure
for me i am trying to orchestrate my
chaotic week of november
for my stuff as well so for me of course
it's gonna be you know destiny on the
10th
and then i'm really trying to decide
between
demon souls potentially god fall all of
that stuff that's coming out and then of
course cyberpunk
uh i got lucky enough to be an
ambassador for outriders so i'm still
working on orchestrating that one
so a lot of stuff coming um yeah
november through
who knows when i'm probably not gonna
get much more sleep if i can help it as
well so
stay tuned to the channel it's ibontist
everywhere twitch twitter youtube
if you see the cheetah and that name
you've probably found me
so thank you very much for episode 124
chat you guys have been amazing hang
tight i'm gonna go raid another destiny
stream of course when we're done so we
got to do that
but for this episode episode 124 october
16th
i think we'll wrap it here so it has
been
the last word